[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome hello
welcome to the first uh sparks event uh
first edition the serendipity forum at
cern in geneva the theme of today is
future intelligence welcome to those are
here in the beautiful globe of science
and innovation and to all of you
watching
online my name is bruno jose i'm going
to be your host today
the artwork we just saw by the way well
if you ever wonder what happens in a in
a collider in a particle collider that's
one of the versions it's an artwork
based on the collision data from large
hadron collider which is here
underground 100 meters under our feet
and we're gonna learn how that was made
later in the session
so this is the first edition of sparks
we had a digital launch last year
and
this event is actually a two days event
there is a forum took place yesterday is
a more specialized closed event and
this public event today yesterday we had
experts from cern and from around the
world discussing the same theme of today
future intelligence and some of those
discussions are going to percolate into
our uh conversation today but before we
start because these are strange times to
do
events like
this let me say that organizing an event
in time of pandemic is not an easy task
participants here in remote many time
zones a lot of other considerations so i
want to complement and thank the team
and especially sir for taking the
initiative of bringing us back in
presence after so much time
of course we want to ensure that all of
those who are here uh physically
will be here safely and so here are the
rules for the day for you
here at the globe please keep your masks
on at all time and don't forget
distancing and
hand sanitizing
so let's start
sparks the idea of sparks is to
explore artificial intelligence today
and these possible evolutions and how it
overlaps with science and especially
with the science
here at cern which uses ai in many ways
already and we're going to do this in a
multidisciplinary
approach and the program will feature
scientists of course but also ethicists
philosophers psychologists artists and
more
but before getting to the first
guest i want to invite the director
general of cern to provide a glimpse
into why cern is so interested in
artificial intelligence and its future
please welcome fabiola janati
[Applause]
thank you very much bruno for this nice
introduction
to all of you whether you are here in
person or
following us remotely welcome to this
first edition of sparks
and first of all i would like to thank
very warmly our partners without without
which and without
them and their generosity will not be
here today and this initiative will not
have been possible
so this event was developed to um to
spark creativity and we know that
creativity and new ideas are the the
lifeblood of scientific research and
technological development
spark brings experts from different
fields together
to
share their view and their knowledge on
a topic of common interest and possibly
also generate new ideas
and i would like to emphasize that in my
opinion one of the main
lessons that we learn from the pandemic
is that
collaboration across different
disciplines sectors and geographical
borders is absolutely essential for
humanity to face today's challenges and
in crisis and for the future of
of society
the topic of this first edition as
already um anticipated by bruno dussani
is artificial intelligence which at cern
is getting and is becoming more and more
important for our research but also more
important
for society more in general
at cern artificial intelligence helps us
run our facility and also
extract the most interesting physics
results from the huge amount of data
that are recorded by the experiments and
in society as you know
ai finds application range from
healthcare to self-driving vehicles
but
although there is there is of course a
huge potential for human advancement and
progress thanks to ai
we have to make sure that as for any
other technology ai is also used for the
betterment of humanity and for the
sustainability of the planet so for good
and noble
goals
as bruno mentioned yesterday there has
been a forum that has brought together
leading thinkers in the field of ai
they've exchanged view and several new
ideas have surfaced and most of them
will be shared with you today
before concluding let me say that today
we host you in this building called the
global science and and innovation with a
largely uh virtual
audience
but we hope in the future when kobe 19
is behind us to be able to uh to host
you and to welcome many of you in a in a
new building the science gateway which
is now being constructed just a few uh
meters from uh from here a few hundred
meters from here which will be the new
cern flagship um facility for
uh science education and uh outreach uh
construction will end in a few months
from now and we hope to
open to the public in 2023 so i hope to
see many of you and many more uh at cern
uh in the future
but in the meantime waiting for science
gateway to be ready and uh and for now
i'd like to use to wish you a very nice
afternoon uh in a reaching afternoon and
a sparking afternoon thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you
thank you fabiola so the first speaker
is the world authority on human behavior
and decision making daniel kahneman he's
also a co-recipient of the nobel prize
for economics and 10 years ago he
published a book uh called thinking fast
and slow in which he decrypted the two
systems that shape our judgments and
decisions with a significant focus on
cognitive biases now with two co-authors
danielle olivier sibuni and cass
sunstein is if another important book
noise a flaw in human judgment
which explores another way we make
errors
in decision making the noisy quality of
our systems of our context or our
processes
daniel should be online with us
let's see daniel how are you welcome
welcome to sparks
i'm not sure if we hear your voice so
let's try again
oh yes we do now we do now yes it's
perfect daniel is perfect thank you very
much thank you for being with us
let's start with the the basics
literally the title of the book noise
can you describe it for us what do you
mean by noise
well
what i mean by noise is really the same
as the measurement void
it is unwanted variability
so when people are judging the same
thing
in a system where you would like them to
speak in one voice if they don't speak
in one voice
that is noise
and
we have found that wherever there is
judgment there is noise and there is
much more of it than most people expect
that's why we wrote the book so how is
the different from from bias there's
been a lot of attention on bias in
recent years and very little on on noise
how is that different
well it's easiest to explain by thinking
about measurement of distance
so when you're measuring
a line the length of the line with a
very fine ruler
there's going to be variability in your
measurements
that variability the standard deviation
of your measurement is air is noise the
average error in your measurement that
is bias
and in the theory of measurement
noise and bias
the standard formula for
inaccuracy for global error is by the
square of bias plus the square of noise
and that applies as well to judgments
when the goal of judgments is accuracy
so
if i understand correctly the the
we can we can see
inaccuracy in terms of bias in in like a
single decision we cannot see noise in a
single decision noise is more of a
collective aggregated kind of kind of
problem is that correct
absolutely
noise
is a statistical concept you need an
ensemble of cases to detect noise bias
is actually a sort of causal notion so
we that makes it a lot easier to think
about bias because you can see bias
affecting or imaginary bias affecting a
single decision but you will never find
noise in a single decision so how
keeping in mind we are talking to to a
global audience here via the live stream
how do we reduce noise in decision
making in our daily decision making
well
in the book we propose
the notion of decision hygiene
those are steps that one can take
when one is making judgments
deliberately and slowly whether
individually or as in a group that will
tend to reduce noise and actually reduce
bias as well
and there are a number of them the most
obvious one
is just having multiple people make a
judgment of the same case because
unlike bias
noise is reduced systematically with the
number of observation or with a number
of independent judgments
so
any other procedures yeah indeed you
indicate another but
are you suggesting that the more noise
there is the more we need
a number of different inputs to be able
to reduce it
or different decisions yeah
so there is another mechanism described
in the book which is essentially to
create rules or of or or algorithms to
to go through which
comes down to either checklist or
breaking down the property in different
pieces and of all series of things tell
us about that tell us about that
mechanism for using noise
well uh
any rule and any algorithm has a
characteristic that it is noise-free
that when you apply the rule or apply
the algorithm twice on the same problem
you are going to get the same answer
this is not true of human judgment
and it turns out in a great deal of
research
that one of the main advantages in many
cases the one advantage
of algorithms and rules over human
judgment is that they are noise-free and
human judgment is very noisy
for example i have an inherent advantage
over humans
against noise
is that correct
it's it's correct and actually in
multiple domains i mean this is known to
everyone but in domains that even
include
uh justice and medical diagnosis
uh
algorithms are already superior to human
judgment
and it's clear that an algorithm are
almost equivalent to
a human judgment
question of time in a very short time
the algorithm becomes superior this was
true for stress
it's true for areas of medical diagnosis
it's true for judgment for
judicial
decision
at least easy decisions like in the case
of pale
yet there is
the hell can they kind of understand
because the tumor is a tumor
in the case of the judicial process
there is a margin of appreciation by the
judge and by the prosecutor etc how do
you build that into the system that has
to sift through noise
well
the amount of noise in the judicial
system is simply shocking
just to give you an indication in an
experiment
in a study of federal judges when the
average uh
sentence for a crime is seven years
the average difference between two
judges is four years
this is the lottery that the defendant
faces when a defendant is faced with the
judge so there is a lot of rules for
reducing
noise in the judicial system okay let's
let's bring this down to the level of
the individual uh i go home tonight and
i feel overwhelmed by all the
information of the world which is part
of the noise you're facing right all
these channels and and the amounts of
information that come our way how do i
look at this in terms of noise and
reducing noise as an individual then i'm
going to ask you the same question for
the scientist
well uh as an individual
the principle is actually fairly simple
the rules of decision hygiene
and there are several principles of this
they have been verified in research on
groups of judgments but in fact the
individual judge the decision hygiene
applies just as well when you're making
individual decisions as when you are
making repeated decisions
and
so it's a matter of
slowing down but slowing down is only
one aspect of it it's what you do when
you slow down that is likely
what we should do when you slow down
exactly what was the process there
well
that is of course a long story but to
give
one example which is it will sound
trivial except that people don't do it
it is that when you are facing a
decision problem
breaking up the problem into aspects and
evaluating each aspect independently of
the others
and waiting
to form a general until the end until
the profile of attributes is complete
that turns out to be non-intuitive and
it turns out to be quite important there
are two principles here one
aspects of judgment have to be
independent of each other that's a basic
statistical rule for efficiency
and the other is to delay intuition
where there is judgment you don't want
to eliminate intuition but you want to
delay it so that it is based on as much
information as possible those are the
best principles but they work out in
detail when you have to read the book
let me let me ask you two two final
questions one is
we have seen over and over in the last
several years algorithms being deeply
biased is there a risk that they're
going to be crippled also because there
is too much noise in the data
well
uh
the main character
well
the biasing algorithm is not an inherent
characteristics of algorithm it's a it
is a
it's a result of mistakes that people
make in building the algorithm
especially in the choice of dependent
variables so bias is really not inherent
in in algorithmic decision making and
algorithmic decision making is
essentially guaranteed to reduce noise
and
if it is based on a sufficiently large
body of data and done competently then
algorithmic decision making is going to
be
relatively free of bias and especially
free of noise now is is there
are there some sectors or or cases where
reducing noise is not the goal for
example there is a school of thought
that things that some disorder some
messiness some chaos is kind of
fundamental for creativity for example
uh
is is is noise essential to creativity
i i think that there are
the the domains in which you want to
reduce noise are fairly specific
and this is when you have for example an
organization you and individuals who
speak for the organizations like judges
speak for the judicial system
underwriters speak for an insurance
company physicians in some sense speak
for the medical system then you want the
representatives of the system to speak
in one voice
but when you want to solve problems when
you want to be creative then of course
diversity is essential and diversity is
essential in the process of decision
making
before you reach conclusions when you
reach conclusions you're hoping that
there will be as little noisy as
possible
danielle thank you for being with us and
to be uh available for operating sparks
event thank you very much enjoy the rest
of the day
[Applause]
so the next segment is going to be about
constructing ai what are the missing
building blocks for uh artificial
intelligence and also what are the
latest developments in in the field
we're going to explore that with two
speakers first anima anand kumar uh
she's a professor at caltech director of
machine learning at nvidia where she
leads the research group developing next
generation ai algorithms
but at cal tech she also co-leads a
group called ai for science
which focuses on bringing modern ai
tools to science and engineering please
welcome anima
[Applause]
thank you it's a pleasure to be here my
first event
since the pandemic and such a great way
to come out of it
so artificial intelligence is the most
powerful force of our time
we've seen such impressive gains over
the last few years
now we are at the realm of language
understanding
having models so large that they can
produce
coherent pieces of text
we are now looking to building
intelligent robots both in the air and
on the ground
and we are looking towards solving hard
scientific problems such as discovering
new drugs
and ultimately problems that are greatly
beneficial to humanity
what has led to this progress is an
impressive growth in model complexity
it's mind-boggling to think that the
models have grown
30 000 times over the last five years
and it's doubling every two months
this is highly impressive
what has led to this explosive growth is
what i call the trinity of ai
we have deep neural network algorithms
being powered by large-scale data sets
and the computing infrastructure
especially the parallelism of nvidia
gpus
so this synergy of data algorithms and
compute has led to this explosive growth
of ai
over the last decade
so the question is where do we go next
is this all what we need or do we need
to be much more mindful of the new
algorithms we design
and to answer that what we really need
is to go for generalizable ai
right now most of ai is very narrow it's
trained for usually one task
on the other hand that's not how our
brain works
you just heard daniel canman talk about
slow thinking no we have pretty good
instincts but so much of what we do
doesn't just rely on that we have the
system too
where we slow down you know we look at
all the facts and then we reason about
that
and what drives this is also interactive
learning we are always like testing the
environments you see infants touching
things trying to walk trying to look at
everyone that interaction is so critical
to build this bridge from learning to
reasoning
and that is what we need to build in our
ai systems for broad generalization for
robustness so that it can work in the
real world
and so that it can go to entirely unseen
scenarios and make new discoveries
and one critical aspect of this slow
thinking
is
the availability of feedback
in our brain we are not just taking in
external signals such as from the retina
but we also have an internal model where
there is feedback
and this feedback is slower than just
the feed forward mechanism
and this in totality creates visual
perception
and so if we abstract these kind of
concepts such as feedback we can build
now neural networks that are not just a
composition of feed forward layers
but have an internal generative model
and drive feedback to create more robust
learning
and also be able to learn just few
examples like humans do
and so this kind of inspiration in terms
of how our intelligence is grounded in
feedback can be greatly beneficial to
creating better deep neural networks
the other important aspect is embodiment
like i said interaction is so critical
for art learning
and so to do that we need to create
robots that are intelligent
so you see this impressive atlas robot
boston dynamics robot that can do an
impressive backflip
but what is more lovable and what is
more intelligent it's the dog
right so even though it may fumble it
may fail it's learning you know it's
taking our commands it's always adapting
and that kind of intelligence is still
far from what the robots can do
and so how do we enable robot learning
at nvidia we built the platform called
isac that can have physically valid
simulations accelerated by gpus
and with this we can now try all kinds
of different experiments right you can
do treadmill in different speeds and we
can also build primitives and learn how
to mix with reinforcement learning
and with this with the multitask setting
we can now test the robot in entirely
unseen scenarios
this baseline with no learning is gonna
fall on this proverbial banana appeal
with no friction
but the learned robot is more robust
and also we can transfer it to the real
world to the real robot and
and you know show robustness and have
different tasks be done in the real
world as well
so this notion of going from simulation
to the real world can enable embodied ai
and that requires not just the design of
new environments but also new algorithms
with the notion of hierarchical learning
to enable
finally robust real-world deployment
the other important aspect is safety you
know we don't want our drones to crash
right we want it to be intelligent and
adaptive
so this drone here is tracking
trajectory very close to the ground and
this is enabled by learning the
aerodynamics in a data-driven manner
or we can also try to handle high wind
speed you know potentially very unsafe
for a standard drone but with now
learning you can handle even these
challenging scenarios
and that's where we can harness the
power of learning while maintaining
safety guarantees for these challenging
scenarios
and indeed we can ask how do we solve
hard scientific problems of all times
from tackling climate change to
understanding the fundamental properties
of our molecules and atoms
what is the role of ai here
so one aspect we've looked in the last
year is to design neural networks that
can learn complex systems
such as those described by partial
differential equations
and this requires us to think beyond
standard neural networks that learn
only in finite dimensions
meaning they expect say images of a
fixed size
on the other hand when we are solving
these complex systems
we have a continuous function right we
should be able to handle all kinds of
resolution all kinds of different grids
and so we need a versatile framework for
handling such scenarios
and we created one called neural
operator
and what it's able to do is learn
complex fluid flows you can see it here
be able to evaluate in higher
resolutions than it's trained on so it's
cheap to train and it's thousand times
faster than the standard solvers
and that's where you see the power of ai
in being able to
learn complex systems and be able to
generalize seamlessly while being much
faster than traditional methods
we've also seen that with quantum
chemistry
indeed the primary equation is the
schrodinger's equation if we can solve
this we've solved everything
right but even to do that on a small
molecule with about 100 atoms it would
take
more than the age of the universe to run
on today's supercomputers
so how do we build ai methods that can
do good approximations and get us
accurate quantum level properties
so we combined molecular orbitals these
you can think as domain specific
features with graph neural networks
which are versatile and flexible
and by doing this careful combination
what we achieved was the ability to
train just on small molecules and
directly evaluate on much larger
molecules so this transferability allows
us to study important properties for
drugs such as geometry optimization and
do that again thousand times faster than
the current methods
so in conclusion what i talked today
is to
move from just learning to reasoning and
that's what will enable generalizable ai
and for this we need feedback we need a
generative model and the ability to
combine that to make predictions
effectively
ai for science is the future of science
and ai has
shown already promising results with
enormous speedups as well as good
generalization
thank you
[Applause]
thank you mina
a second perspective on constructing ai
uh is from cry kavok shoglow who is the
vice president of research at deepmind
deepmind is part of alphabet which is
the modern company of
google and is possibly the leading ai
company in the world let's listen cry
welcome to sparks
thank you very much it's a pleasure to
be here as anima said after a long pause
on everything
and
i'm excited to talk about the importance
of real world challenges for building
artificial general intelligence
our world is full of fundamental
challenges and whose solutions the
solutions to those challenges can make
huge impact on everyone on the world
at deepmind our goal is to build
intelligence solve intelligence to
benefit humanity and to advance science
and while doing that we look at a lot of
research problems a lot of simulations
but at the same time we try to tackle
many of those scientific and engineering
challenges too and in doing that our
goal is to our goal is to create more
and more general methods and algorithms
methods that cancel multiple of these
problems at a given time
and at the same time we want to verify
that the path that we are taking to
solve agi is actually one that is
meaningfully and positively impactful on
the world
now when we think about agi research we
must think about two main domains a
world environment
and an agent
that is acting in that environment
and this kind of thinking leads to two
main classes of algorithms
prediction models that are in the world
environments that can learn that
environment and then can produce future
predictions in that environment and
control algorithms that go inside the
agents and enable those agents to make
intelligent actions in that environment
now a successful path to developing agi
has to have solutions and understanding
for the problems in both of these
domains
for example alpha fold is a great
achievement to be able to predict the 3d
structures of proteins is already
a huge leap forward in biology
and we hope that it will help understand
diseases better and potentially lead to
better drug discoveries
on the control side we have developed
agents which learn to play challenging
games like go by themselves and also we
have worked on industrial control
systems today i will go i'll give two
examples of new research areas that we
have worked on one from each side of
these domains
first a collaboration that we have done
with the uk meta office which provides
methodological forecasting but at the
same time it is a leading research
institute in climate science together
we have looked at the problem of now
casting
it is the capability of being able to
predict the rainfall in the next five
minutes to two hours
this is a critical ability because it
impacts decision making in important
areas such as emergency services energy
management
flood warning systems
and weather prediction
is a very challenging problem
it is almost impossible to precise the
model with classical techniques
at the same time it is a domain where
there is a lot of data available
and with the current ai methods that we
are developing we can leverage that data
we can learn from that data and then we
can use those models to make future
predictions
the models that we have developed for
this particular work has actually been
researched using research data sets to
generate images and videos
and it is great example that we see
these models transferring from these
research domains into something so
critical into an application like
predicting accurate weather patterns
here you see the comparison between the
planes generated from our model and the
ground route to be able to create such
accurate predictions the model relies on
two main components a special and a
temporal component working together
to produce these patterns
what is important is this model is
trained only from data in an end-to-end
manner
and once it is trained
taking 20 minutes of weather data
it can produce predictions up to two
hours into the future
in our agi research these prediction
models are in the environment space and
the predictions the future forecast
produced from this model is then used by
the agent in this case real humans
expert forecasters who actually get help
from the predictions of these models to
make better decisions better forecasts
i think this is a great example
how ai models can actually be useful in
the context of human decision making
it is also an example where i hope that
this model
is actually contributing to the
understanding of our climate
the second example that i wanted to talk
about on the control side is a
collaboration that we had with epfl
leading research university here in
switzerland
with their experimental fusion reactor
we looked at the problem of plasma
control
fusion is one of the root note solutions
to probably the biggest problem in the
world and in itself it contains multiple
significant challenges and plasma
control is one of them which we have
focused
it's the domain
where we do not have a lot of
experimental data
but physicists over the years have
created very accurate simulators
and using those simulators we can train
agents we can trade control systems
that learn by interacting with that
simulator and only through that
interaction with the simulator we can
train very accurate control systems and
then with zero shot transfer into the
real fusion reactor they successfully
control the plasma
the algorithms that is developed in this
case were actually first developed in
our robot research domain
and then it is great to see again that
these algorithms actually can be
transferred to a challenging application
like plasma control in fusion reactors
here you see the inside view of the
tokamak reactor and on the right you see
the reconstruction of the plasma
you can see that the ai policy can
precisely control the shape and location
of the plasma
and it learns to do this only by
following the blue dots that you see
it is very important to be able to do
that because the plasma inside the
reactor is actually even hotter than the
sun
so to be able to control its shape and
location so that it doesn't touch the
boundaries the walls and an efficient
structure is a critical problem
the system learns to do that
by using around 100 input measurements
from the reactor
and outputs control signals for magnets
and it has to repeat that 10 000 times a
second on such a
high frequency
moreover
it is not able to do that only for that
particular configuration it is actually
a general system that can do many
different configurations and it is
important to be able to generalize to
these many configurations because these
different structures help the fusion
researchers understand their problem
better
we hope that with the capability that ai
brings to do easily doing plasma control
the researchers in fusion can actually
come up with new ways to think about
their problem and better progress in
their research
in both of these examples that we have
looked at we have collaborated with
experts in their domains and they were
excellent collaborations and a huge
thanks and credit goes to those teams
i believe that agi is one of the most
important things that we can work on as
scientists
and while doing that obviously we have a
lot of challenges in our own domain in
terms of learning to transfer learning
efficiently understanding causality and
understanding time
but we will continue to apply our
methods to these real world challenges
so that we can get to more and more
general algorithms and make sure that we
are making positive impact
just like alpha fault weather prediction
and plasma control there are many other
scientific and engineering challenges in
the world
and researchers from all different
fields
can come together to work on these to
accelerate our progress for the solution
of these problems and science is the
common language that we can use
to improve our collaborations to enable
those collaborations between different
fields and different researchers
i am personally very excited to see what
our agi research is going to contribute
in many of these problems
thank you very much
thank you
i think i want to clarify first up
question of language because you spoke
about generalized ai you spoke about
artificial general intelligence so
what's the difference here 25 for people
listening yeah so
for me like generalization is much more
of an emphasis right going beyond narrow
generalization between training and
testing of the same distribution to more
broader generalization
whereas agi at least among the public
tends to be confused to human level
intelligence so to avoid that confusion
you know it's mostly you shifted the
language yes
generalization you didn't shift it but
probably you have a different definition
of agi than what the general public has
yeah i mean agi is i think as anime said
it is what is important is um for these
algorithms to be really general
algorithms to be able to solve multiple
problems not but just not just one
problem and when faced with a new
problem to be able to transfer their
knowledge into solution of that problem
so yes i agree with anima that like
generalization in the really
extended sense
i like to keep using that term because i
think it's a precise technical term and
i i agree that there is some confusion
but hopefully with forums like this we
can actually resolve those okay
of those challenges you have identified
at the end causality time and so on
do they need to be tackled all at the
same time or is there one that's
priority because that will help solve
the other or so how would you go after
that
um like they don't need to be tackled at
the same time but obviously i think we
need to
do research on all of them as much as
possible most of the time one finding in
one problem actually translates to the
other one it gives us more traction in
many other problems that we do but these
are all important problems that we
should continue working on because
at least with our understanding
currently these are important um sort of
bottlenecks that we need to be able to
uh improve our our research on yeah so
there is a whole aspect about you know
taking data from the real world and and
using it in the system et cetera but you
mentioned something midway in your talk
that that i found
uh striking you talked about
consciousness and the way you talked
about it you said
consciousness is a key element of
generalized ai
does that mean that we need to
understand consciousness before being
able to get into generalized ai because
we don't understand it now indeed bruno
i think there are many theories around
consciousness and we still don't
understand the mechanisms in the brain
but i think it's commonly agreed in the
neuroscience community that feedback is
an important aspect of it right so we're
consulting with our internal model in
the brain of some sort to ask is this
consistent with the external signals we
are getting so that kind of inspiration
could help us build uh better ai models
so i'm talking at that abstract level
rather than the actual mechanisms
practical the ai for science uh
initiative
in 2018 if i'm uh not mistaken so what
has happened what what has it achieved
in the
time that has passed yeah i mean celtic
is a unique place to house ai for
science because it's a small community
very collegial and we have the world's
expert in so many scientific domains
nobel prize winners but they're willing
to disrupt their own methods to bring ai
and see these gains so bringing these
people together having interdisciplinary
collaborations happen have workshops we
have machine learning graduate students
volunteer their time every week and you
know have these interactions that can
then lead to
very interesting results like what we
see with solving partial differential
equations or quantum chemistry so it
requires really building the bridge and
having the common language of math as
well as machining come together is it
localized only at caltech or do you
collaborate with others can it be
exported somewhere else yeah so it's
also broader than that you know
especially through my nvidia
collaborations we have connections with
different national labs universities so
it's really bringing everybody together
okay right one last question
i am interested in your example about
weather forecast with the met office
essentially
what you say is we have a ton of past
data because of a ton of past data we
can actually really create models that
allow us to be incredibly granular for
whatever period of time you showed two
hours but it probably can be can be
longer
the problem is that
the climate is changing the weather
patterns are changing and so
and yet we're basing the models on old
data how do you adjust for that because
you know just in the last summer we have
had examples of
floods in germany that were not
predicted even one hour before for
example so if
the actual real life
situation changes and doesn't map on the
past data anymore what do you do
well excellent question i think there
are two things there one of them is
there are different time scales that
these changes happen and the data that
we rely on
actually can be shifted forward because
it is operating in the very small time
scale but more importantly what you are
pointing to is actually an excellent
problem which one of the fundamental
problems that i mentioned about like
transfer learning efficiency being able
to continue your learning not
necessarily just train something as a
snapshot in time but actually a model
that can continually ingest data and
continuously update its model and learn
from that is another big challenge that
a lot of research is going in today okay
anima thank you thank you thank you
thank you
so before we move to the next segment i
want to mention the partners who have
believed in sparks and supported the
initiative uh throughout the year
despite the uncertainties uh that
surround us every every day and so on
behalf of the organizers i want to talk
tank rolex and wonder shield and the
foundation martin prima merci beaucoup
[Applause]
also remember that mapping at the
beginning uh based on the data from
chadron collider that took over half of
the globe well i want to understand how
it was made because there were reasons
why i was made like that so i want to
invite ferdi alichi from the company who
created its studio oach to come on stage
and tell us
about it thank you
and how that thing was made oh it was
amazing actually all that things
starting with the
claudia invitation thank you so much
about that
so we collaborated with the
machine learning of the cern team
approximately two months
as a guide as a mentor that was amazing
time in our studio because we could
understand to the two particle moment
time inside of the cern so the data used
in this research provided by the
particle exclamator is the recording of
the moment that the two subatomic
particles collide so these collisions
are such
infinite temperature events that for
human projection of time and space
and they are virtually non-existent
yet took the power of modern science or
collection of events as feeling as the
collision of two subatomic particles
yields gigabytes
of multi-dimensional data
that in turn could be used to unlock
mysteries of the universe
so we are using the data as a paint
algorithm as a brush we're trying
understanding to bounce
of art
research by research relationship
between art science technology ai and
new media art
which is also a way to take that
complexity and bring it down to a visual
level that
is understandable by the general public
now tell me this is one version but you
could have developed an infinite number
of versions based on the same data right
yes exactly actually we use the auto
counter
algorithms a kind of the machine
learning so we can use the 40
dimensional data from the cern and we we
optimize that that data as a seven or
eight different dimension data and we
can use that data uh
as a transform as an architectural
installation
uh
from that ai output okay i think we're
gonna keep in mind that that that
metaphor of the data as the paint and
the
algorithm as the brush
thank you very much yes thank you thank
you great job
[Applause]
so
ai is a field that's developing very
actually seeing the presentations
already several examples of
real applications it's also already
incredible distributed you know ai
algorithms already run on our phones on
our laptops they decide what we see what
we read what we watch uh and what we do
so they don't have to have
human level intelligence in order to
have global scale impact they already
have global scale
impact which brings us of course to the
question of the potential downsides of
ai does ai pose a risk to society now
our next guest is coming in virtually
jan talin is
the founding engineer of skype
an application a piece of software
that's transformed the way we uh
communicate he's also the founder now
of
the center for the study of existential
risk and the co-founder of the institute
the future of life institute so it's
going to be with us to discuss the
downsides and the risks of
ai yan are you there
dean ahem hi how are you
i'm very good very good excellent
excellent
yeah let's start from those two
institutes that you founded and
co-founded future of life
existential risk of course those two
things are tied not only because you are
in both but clearly you see a link so
how do we frame the question of
existential risk today
so there are kind of multiple ways to
frame existential risk
like some of the more sophisticated some
some less but i think kind of like for
practical purposes
uh it would be useful to just like think
about human extinction uh just kind of
going extinct a species as as many other
species on this planet have gone so
the the
the context in which you operate
generally historically forever since the
beginning of time has been dominated by
one dominant species and for the last
several hundred thousand years it has
been humans basically what you're
suggesting with the work of these two
institutes is that this may be about to
change
indeed uh i mean i totally agree with uh
anima who said that
ai seems to be the most powerful force
of our time
uh and indeed i'm kind of worried that
it might be kind of too powerful for our
own good
so identify so you've put out a list a
while ago
of the top existential risks and ai
comes first even before synthetic
biology and others uh unknown unknowns i
think was the third one uh
tell us what the in your view the main
dangers of ai as it is developed today
make us a short list like the top two or
three
um
i would
i would say that like there are
short-term dangers and long-term dangers
so like and short-term dangers are
basically dangerous from ai that was
invented a few years ago and that is now
getting deployed things like face
recognition uh helping um
increasing the power differentials uh
and what not and like
biases and decision making but then that
test long term this is long-term
concerns and long-term concerns are
about ai that doesn't exist yet but
possibly uh could be invented i mean
later later today or or or next year or
next decade
so
and the danger from there really come
from the fact that uh we are very
fragile uh as biological species on this
planet like if it's like if you change
the temperature here by just five
degrees uh that's like how clearly
everybody acknowledges that this is like
a global problem
but like for ai
by default they i would not care about
the environment so like if you end up
sharing the world with uh
sufficiently powerful systems that do
not care about the environment we might
lose the habitability of the environment
so you're seeing ai as a potential
danger around
the climate and for the environment
exactly
there's been
literally dozens of attempts at figuring
out uh an ethical or regulatory
framework for ai on the regulatory side
the things like the european union
putting out a plan for uh for regulation
on the ethical side dozens of committees
and groups and and so proposing ethical
charts for uh for uh ai
do any of those strike you as
appropriate or strong enough or workable
i highly commend
those
attempts
as i commend
technology regulation in general because
technology is a neutral force
that kind of needs additional
constraints in order to remain positive
uh but i do think that there is clearly
like nowhere near enough like the the
big problem
is that
like humanity just doesn't possess the
knowledge how to constrain something
that is potentially more powerful that
is potentially more competent planner
than we are so like it's uh
so
what this suggests is that right now we
just we need more research you know to
figure out like how to how to constrain
uh powerful things like ai and then uh
look at what are the reasonable things
to regulate
so it's a proposal how do we constrain
that
i mean as i said i don't know
but like i do think that on a meta level
things that
sound very valuable
are again
kind of having more people think about
this thing uh that's like for one and
indeed i'm i'm trying to do my best to
increase that number uh then perhaps
think about more things that
we want our regulatory bodies to have
our own more abstract capabilities like
uh
i claim that it would be valuable to
start thinking about if it turns out
that we need to
limit the power of data centers for
example how much concentration per
square kilometer of compute uh we can
have
unregulated uh it might be a good time
to kind of start thinking about it i'm
not saying that it's gonna should do
that now but it would be great uh if
that need wouldn't catch us by surprise
and then finally i think very important
thing is just like international
cooperation thinking about like this hey
i think if it gets sufficiently powerful
it will impact us as species it's not
going to be like u.s thing or chinese
thing or european thing this will be
like a
thing that just like it affects everyone
on this planet so like the more
kind of preparation in international
level we can do in advance the better
yeah that doesn't seem to be to be
something likely to happen right now but
uh uh so but on the point on the point
before uh so basically you're saying if
we really can't regulate something
that's about to become bigger than us as
itself we can probably put limits on the
inputs so on how much computing power
can go towards it how much energy can go
towards it how much data can be inputted
into it that's a little bit the the
place where you see a potential
intervention
yeah so that i think is like something
that is definitely doable i think it's
much more doable than kind of limiting
certain kinds of algorithms and whatnot
which are much harder to regulate
do you think that that companies uh
and markets can kind of self-regulate
uh there is a lot of hope uh that i have
in that area indeed uh
like for example i used to be on the
board of deep mind uh from where corey
uh is
and uh like one
big push uh that i kind of report was
successful to actually have people uh
that are working full-time on long-term
safety issues
and i think as there's certainly like a
massive increase in kind of awareness
among a researchers in general that this
is a big problem
that we need to do our homework on and
and therefore are going to remain
optimistic that the
people who are close to the trenches so
to speak actually are going to do a lot
of homework then of course there is a
question of very big potential upside of
of ai right to go back to your example
about climate and
in the environment ai allows us to bet
to get better climate modeling and this
kind of things so we need to find the
balance between those two things
oh yeah so i
i mean i i care about all the
existential risks uh like if if you go
extinct like i know i don't think it's
so important like which way we do
but i do think that ai is like high
leverage in that sense that if he if he
managed to figure out how to do it like
powerful general ai safely
then we are in a much better position to
address the other extension risks
including including from synthetic
biology
to nuclear to asteroids and whatnot
whereas like if it just fixed asteroid
risk like we still have all the other
risks to contend with okay yeah thank
you for coming to sparks even though
only virtually thank you very much enjoy
the rest of the day thank you very much
bye
so great promises as we have seen before
with anima and korai uh serious risks as
well and big challenges
how
what are the main frameworks to think
through this uh to consider all these
issues to make ai safer but at the same
time use its potential develop its
potential we're going to devote the next
segment to that to ethics and
ai is it a good and evil kind of
situation who makes the rules this kind
of questions and our next speaker is
anya kasperson
she brings to this a number of different
experiences actually uh she's been in
humanitarian work with the international
committee of the red cross she has been
office for disarmament affairs
and is now a senior fellow at the
carnegie carnegie council focusing on
ethics and the international question
anya the stage is yours
[Applause]
so thank you so much and um i will pick
up from somewhere some of my colleagues
left and amina in particular spoke about
how ai is a very powerful tool for
science
but it's also a story of the shifts of
power
who holds power who has agency of
influence in this new world
and while it's clear that ai systems
offer opportunities across various
domains
and contexts which we heard some about
what amounts to responsible perspective
on their ethics and governance is yet to
be realized and few have accomplished
any real impact in modulating its
effects
and we know that ai systems and
algorithmic technologies are being
embedded in scale far more quickly than
the maturity of the technology supports
currently and existing governance
frameworks are still evolving but why
are we not getting it right
allow me to share a few reflections and
maybe along the way debunk a few myths
or at least leave you with some
questions to ask and i think that's
very core to this whole debate about ai
is learning how to ask good questions as
it permates ai-based systems are
permitting our lives
first too often the debate on ai is
presented as a technology will evolve on
its own separate trajectory
this is not the case
it is human all the way every novelty
every challenge every bias every value
every opportunity
we are at an inflection point but it is
a human and to some degree political
some would even say that it's a
theological one but it's certainly not a
technical one
second
many of the existing dialogues are too
narrow and fail to understand the
subtleties and life cycle of an ai
system and there's sometimes limited
functionality and impact we heard some
of this task orientation as we discussed
in another
case
and it's important to remember that it
is a very task focused tool currently
moreover the scientific methods and
complexity underpinning what the what
and the how and the why
of an ai system is poorly understood by
decision makers
we thus need a better scientific and
anthropological intelligence both when
building foundational models but also in
how we think about future applications
of artificial intelligence
third the debate focus on some aspects
of ethics while ignoring other aspects
that are more fundamental and sometimes
more challenging
for example what potential might they
have to perpetuate existing inequalities
and create new ones
we heard daniel kahneman speak about the
noise and decision making
about the human
complexity in decision making
and how some decisions might
perpetuating certain biases while a
machine algorithmic is no different
but in the ethics field this is called
the ethics washing creating a
superficially reassuring but illusory
sense that ethical systems and issues
are being adequately addressed to
justify pressing forward systems that
end up deepening current patterns
fourth i call it the overfitting
over promising over premising and on the
delivering trap
in a variety of sensitive systems from
healthcare to employment to justice to
defense we are rolling out ai systems
that may be brilliant at identifying
correlations but do not understand
causation or consequences something that
also courage spoke to
this carries with significant risks
especially when deployed into
politically fragile context or when
deployed in the public sector
fifth discussions on ai and ethics are
still largely confined to power
more informed public discourse and
serious investment in civic education
digital literacy diverse participation
as we also heard in the
daniel kahneman address
transdisciplinarity
around the societal impacts of the
bio-digital revolution is highly
necessary
sixth too much of what the generally
currently perceives about ai comes from
sci-fi troops and blockbuster movies we
need better ways to communicate to the
public that beyond the hypothetical
risks of future of ai some of which we
just heard about there are real and
imminent limitations posed by why and
how we embed ai systems that currently
shape everyone's daily lives and who
gets to decide when and how to do it
seventh the public discourse on ai is
not sufficiently addressing downstream
consequences
too often focus on myopic tax
solutionist optimization approaches
rather than what problem we're trying to
solve and what their problem requires
sometimes that's not ai
i call this the ai pixie dust problem
this includes how to reduce any
potential environmental impact from
resource-intensive computations
issues concerning data ownership
to how we cultivate talent build digital
literacy and aim fluency and create
shared spaces and vernacular to share
insights
we spoke about science as a new language
but it's also important of making sure
for to have a transdisciplinary dialogue
that we have a shared vernacular to
really be able to
do that meaningfully
specific hard questions really enter
into the public discourse despite its
importance to safely embedding ai
systems into the public realm
these include concerns about
interruptability of ai systems
how and how and can we truly design and
build both failed safe but also fail
secure mechanisms into ai systems so
they safely interrupt and protect
themselves if an unexpected change in
circumstances be that weather patterns
or something else
leads them to cause harm or the
potential of harm the jury seems to
still be out on this one and regulations
remain embryonic or opaque at best
interoperability is another
underappreciated problem from autonomous
vehicles to financial technologies and
defense applications no matter how well
designed an individual system may be
there is a potential for unanticipated
consequences if it is not able to
operate smoothly with other rhythms
additionally the reach of ai systems
into every aspect of daily life was
dramatically accelerated by the pandemic
lockdowns which shifted more social and
economic activities into the digital
world
leading technology companies now have
effective control of many public
services and digital infrastructures
through protection or outsourcing
schemes
humans and healthcare providers deployed
ai systems and proximity tracking and in
tracing applications and bioinformatic
responses at an unprecedented scale
this has triggered a new economic sector
organized around
the flow of bio data our bio data
another consideration of concern is that
the people who are most vulnerable to
negative impacts from ai are also least
likely to be able to join the
conversation
either because they have no digital
access or their lack of digital literacy
makes them right for exploitation
such vulnerable groups are often
theoretically included in discussions
but not empowered to take a meaningful
part in those same discussions
this engineered inequity alongside human
biases risks amplifies otherness and
worse other ring
true neglect exclusion myths and
disinformation which significant
consequences and these are real issues
we need to tackle
more insidious perhaps is the wider
debate and intentionality versus
unintentionality of the effects of
technology going beyond traditional
discussions of dual use
often this debate features claims of
technology and ai being apolitical in
nature or that there's no way of fully
predicting the impact once it is used
this is interesting the view that is
particularly prominent among
non-technical people
not comprehending that every
technological creation embed values and
values reflect culture and politics and
historical patterns of behavior and
economic realities
in my view it is time to return to the
drawing board and address how to
translate principles into practice
we need to grapple with our blind spots
we need to question if we have the right
platforms do we have the right people
leading them do we have empowered people
to engage with it sufficiently
in some ways i've been here at sir now
for a few days and we had this amazing
interdisciplinary discussions sharing
views
and i really think we need to learn from
the cern experience that collaboration
can provide a very effective checks and
balances to make sure we get it right to
make sure that we have a responsible
science and responsible evolution of
this technology we also need to be clear
on what aspect of ethics are we
considering and which are we overlooking
are we looking them with intention or
unintentionally we also we need to be
aware of whose rules whose values and
interests are we embedding into our
technologies
i will leave it with that
pretty much
ania don't leave stay with me stay with
me okay
uh we only have a couple of minutes so i
want to ask you a question for a quick
answer and then maybe we look if there
is a question from social media but you
have this unique background military
humanitarian technology
what can we learn from the experience in
dealing for instance with nuclear
weapons
for the way we're gonna deal with ai
after all they're both gigantic
scientific projects turned into
big uh systems massive systems
controlled by a limited number of
players so what can we learn from 50
years of experience more
in nuclear weapons
that we can apply to ai
i think there's so three quick answers
to that so one is what we can learn from
the arms control in general
then there's the nuclear science and
also relate this back to the cern thing
um and let me actually let me start with
a certain thing you know one of the
unique things i've heard of the last few
days is how physicists here say
that speaking about limitations actually
empowers their research it makes their
science better that's the type of
discussion we need to have when we speak
about algorithmic technologies we also
need to rethink the concepts we use in
the world of ai and a lot of
non-tangible
assets we no longer can speak about
deterrence in the same way as we did in
the nuclear area what can we learn from
the arms control in general
if you don't keep focus on what you're
trying to verify how you do the testing
validation certification reviews
transparency process and the
verification it is very difficult to get
a treaty that can you fully implement
and that's something we can learn
because once you try to apply those
lessons from the arms control into
essentially software architecture type
of pieces where there are vendors and
different processes
verification becomes top and center of
making sure that that is a viable 3d
process let's see if there is a question
from social media if there is one the
team is going to put it up here do you
think that we have oh this is yeah do
you think that we have today the right
platforms the right people so you kind
of
hinted at this at the end but so the
question is
do we have the right platform we have
the right people what what's your
opinion there i would change the
question are we empowering people in the
right way okay to actually engage in
this discussion what i'm seeing for
where i stand is there's a general lack
of what we call ai fluency or digital
literacy so the way we engage in the
debate is often influenced by the fact
that there is a very poor understanding
of each other's field i think having
scientists around the table having the
multi-domain expertise that you know
some of my colleagues were speaking
about but also having the translation
capacity and i noticed that there are
quite a few people on the cern staff
here that now has degrees in science
communication
but also science translation and policy
translation that's the type of people we
need to have around the table do we have
the right people currently
i think we have many of the right people
but i think we need to really really
expand uh the diversity of those who
participate and their ability to
participate meaningfully okay i am thank
you very much thank you thank you
so we're going to shift perspective from
the risk of ai becoming our worst enemy
to the potential of being our best our
best friend and many researchers are
actually focusing on that there is a
subset of that field which is social
embodied ai and the place where there
that's happening faster than
elsewhere is of course uh japan where we
find our next uh speaker hiroshi
ishiguro is a professor of the
department of systems innovation at
osaka university he could not travel to
geneva but he sent us a talk on video
let's watch
[Music]
hello everybody
my name is
i'm going to give a short talk about my
work interactive robots and future
societies
so this is the uh my
goal so i want to realize human robot
symbiotic societies by developing the
interactive robot technologies
the human robot symbiotic societies i
have started my
robot project around 2000
i have spent more than 20 years so far
and i have created these humanoid robots
why do we need humanoid robots the
reason is simple the human has a brain
that recognizes humans
the ideal interface for human is humans
therefore the information media devices
such as talking rice cookers should be
at least especially human-like and a
conversation to understand humans
human-like robots are needed
so this is our approach we call it
constructive science with intelligent
systems
human intelligence comprises elements of
memories computations inference running
etc the challenge is to identify how
these elements can can be put together
for
realizing human intelligence
the constructive approach will
reconstruct robots and androids to model
humans and use such robots and android
to study the human macro level or metal
level functions
so
so far in especially in neuropathics we
have focused on the these
uh well elements and the mechanics
manipulators sensors and image
understandings and the voice
recognitions but after this we need to
focus on these metal level or macro
level cognitive functions actually i
have implemented the intention desire to
our android and and they brought their
fully autonomous conversation android
so um this android is called
android is the sitting in the lobby of
our research institute and talking with
the visitors and usually the robot can
have more than the five five minutes
talks with the new cameras
in action to that
we are developing the
uh child android
the merit of a child android we don't
need to limit the situation the purpose
in the societies so everybody very kind
to the child android and child and can
ask any question to the people the
purpose of the moonshot project is to
realize a society in which people are
free from the constraints of body's
brain space and times by 2050s
our project name is avatar symbiotic
societies
this is the uh
probably the one of the origins of
arbiters okay and then i have improved
that technologies very much and i have
developed the my copy arbiter
in 2006 okay
so
by extending that approach and by
integrating with autonomous robot
technology
my role is to realize these future
societies
anyone including
including the elderlies and people with
disabilities will be able to
freely participate in various activities
with abilities beyond ordinary people
while expanding their physical cognitive
and perceptual abilities using a large
number of cybernetic arbiters
in 2025
we are going to have a world expo in
osaka and kansai areas i'm a semantic
project producers
we are going to use many arbiters
in my praveens
and appear the technologies of
arbiters so i believe
so we can have sustainable societies by
using
the avatar technologies
after the world expo
i hope
we can realize
we can develop the human robot symbiotic
societies
so i believe the most important meaning
of a human robot symbiotic society is
we can have a
chance to think about humans deeply
through the interaction with the robot
thank you for your attention
[Music]
now is the first time i hear about one
individual having its own pavilion at
the world expo but apparently he is so
in 2025 you'll get a proof of concept of
that
idea of an integrated society between
humans and
in artificial agents now
the idea of a space shared by humans and
human
questions of course so to help us
understand some of them better
our next speaker is luiza damiano she's
an associate professor of logic and
philosophy at the university of messina
in italy louisa the stage is yours
[Applause]
so thank you very much for having me
here so uh my talk is about a new kinds
of robots that are already out there and
they are called social robots we saw
some example before but they could we
can think to robotic teachers robotic
nurses even to robotic friends and
robotic lovers and recently these robots
are started to move from science fiction
to our labs and from our labs to our
social context
which means that they are becoming part
of our social world so this is the issue
i would like to propose for discussion
today what do you think about sharing
our private our public spaces hospital
schools but also our homes with these
robots are you afraid of this and tend
to think that these robots will damage
us and our society or you can think or
can see in these robots the potential of
helping us to improve ourselves and our
society so this is the issue i would
like to discuss by considering more
closely uh social robots which are
designed by specialists in social
robotics not as robotic tools for us but
as social partners
that is the idea is that of robots that
can interact with us through our social
signals gestures emotional expression
verbal communication and so on and this
works
in the sense it has been shown that this
skill enriches social robots of what we
call social presence that is the
capability of generating engaging the
users the impression of being with
someone that is not an object not a
person but a social agent that shares
some traits of
people of other person so social
partners in this sense
and how social robots is doing that is
doing that by combining engineering and
science in in the sense that social
robotics is incorporating in these
robots scientific hypothesis about us
about our cognitive our affective our
social processes and then tests this
hypothesis by evaluating the quality of
the interaction of these robots with us
and in this sense we can see every
attempt of introducing one of these
robots in our social context as an
experiment that is telling something
about this hypothesis and so
about us
and in this sense we can think to social
robotics as a science as a synthetic
anthropology a science that is studying
humans by constructing robotic models of
humans that is the science that through
these models is helping us to deepening
our scientific understanding of who we
are but at the same time by diffusing
these robots in our social context is
imposing to us to address the issue of
what we will become through the
introduction of these robots in our
social context
in this these robots will change us we
change the way in which we interact with
technology will become more and more
social this way they will change the way
in which we interact with each other we
experience and we fake social effective
interactions and we cannot foresee the
effects
of these these changes because the same
process through which we will understand
better ourselves and our sociality
through these robots is the same process
through which we will be transformed
based on the introduction of these
robots in our social context
so here the question
how we can orient the diffusion of
social robots towards a positive future
for us and our society and this is one
of the main questions of a new field in
philosophy and ethics of technology that
is ethics of social robots a field that
is divided with regard to this point
indeed the mainstream in this in this
field
tends to recognize in this technology a
cheating technology that cannot be
beneficial to us
the idea is that these robots are not
capable of establishing social relations
like ours so they're fooling us in
making us believe they can
uh on the long term the concern is that
this we will prefer to interact easily
with these robots that difficulty with
other humans and so these robots the
diffusion of the robot will produce
radical form of social isolation which
are good points
these are concrete uh dangers inherent
to this technology
but we consider this point of view more
closely we can see that it can be more
harmful than helpful
let's consider a controversial example
of a robot that is produced and
commercialized today kind of robot and
that is a
sex robot with an integrated rape option
that is is programmed to resist to the
advance of the users in such a way that
the user can impose to the robot sexual
acts
if we consider
this kind of robots applying
the logic that is underlying the ethical
condemnation of these robots we can see
in this violent only simulated violence
because cannot be more real than the
simulated suffering on this of these
robots and so we can start to see the
limits of this point of view
in the sense it's a point of view that
on one side allow the users to consider
unreal the violence they are exercises
on these robots which can be problematic
considering that users tend to see these
robots social partners not objects
on the other side is facing engaging the
ethical inquiry in understanding how the
interaction with these social robots is
changing our etiquette and our social
behavior
so the most likely outcome of this kind
of approach to the ethics of social
robots is not the banning of these
robots but is there an evolution of
social robotics without a focused
ethical research without focused ethical
guidelines so the most probable outcome
will be social robotics driven by in
economical interest so producing more
these robots than other kind of robots
we're already producing like socially
assistive robots designed to help for
example children with special needs to
improve their social is
heavily criticized by this point of view
so that's why
in my view is very important now in the
next years to propose alternatives to
this ethical approach
to social robots alternatives that are
betting on the possibility of using
these robots as tools of
self-development for us so the idea is
that of accepting the challenges that
these robots are proposing to us and
trying to create a positive synergy
between the process of the knowledge and
the process of self-transformation that
we are undergoing through the diffusion
of these robots so the idea is that
for example express this idea in
an approach that we are introducing now
as a synthetic ethics the idea is that
of a research
ethical research integrated in specific
projects of
production of social robots with a
double aim studying the effects on our
social behavior and theoretical behavior
of the interaction with these robots
case by case and then engage engaging
the ethical inquiry in producing better
robots and guidelines to use better
so
the idea is that of transforming the
analysis of risk the risks generated by
these robots in research questions to be
answered through concrete implementation
solutions and concrete ethical
guidelines so how we can build social
robots that are working as social
connectors and not as means of isolation
for us how we can build
robots that are stimulating positive
interaction between humans instead of
weakening our relations
for example how we can beat robot that
are
discouraging us helping us to discourage
the exercise of violence from social
patterns instead of stimulating it so
the idea is that of analytics that is
trying not to reduce but to multiply our
possibilities and here possibility means
of possibilities of positive coevolution
between us also through these robots by
positive coevolutions that is um
through all the discipline can be
fruitfully involved in the creation of
better social robots it is not only
social robotics but also philosophy
epistemology
ethics but also anthropology sociology
and so on so thank you very much for
your attention
thank you louisa thank you very much
please
somebody's going to come and take away
the chair thank you
uh
so to close the session we have another
contribution via video by the man who
literally wrote the textbook on
artificial intelligence stuart russell
from
the university of california at berkeley
we asked him how to get it right and he
sent us this answer let's watch it
[Music]
hi i'm stuart russell i'm sorry i can't
be there in person due to an immovable
conflict
my topic today is what if we succeed
finally
more than 70 years after alan turing's
paper computing machinery and
intelligence
we're starting to discuss this question
by success i mean what if we create
general purpose human level or
superhuman ai
that is ai that can quickly learn to
perform well at any task that humans can
perform and probably many more besides
now the fact that we're discussing it
does not mean that it's imminent in fact
i think we're a long way away our
current ideas
don't work as well as we think they do
and we need some big new ideas as well
as reintegration of some big old ideas
it's very hard to predict when this will
happen but the potential impact is huge
so we still need to talk about it the
economic value of general purpose ai
would be almost incalculable
certainly in the quadrillions of dollars
assuming we solve the problem of
equitable distribution it could make
material goods and services essentially
free
it could also provide significant
advances in science and health and
education on the downside ai is already
being misused in ways that exacerbate
bias
amplify disinformation
enable social control and surveillance
and kill people
as every programmer knows if a computer
can do something once it can do it a
million times with very little extra
work by the programmer and that includes
killing people
now just down the road in geneva is the
home of the un negotiations on lethal
autonomous weapons so i would ask the
nation states who will sit down in
november to discuss this
what will you say to those who are left
after the first large-scale massacre by
machine
will you say oh sorry we never imagined
this was possible
okay
end of moral outrage to return to our
story
what if we succeed
interestingly
alan turing did discuss this question in
a radio lecture in 1951
he said
we should have to expect the machines to
take control
in other words
success in ai could mean the end of
human civilization
i think the reason is that we have been
thinking of ai the wrong way the
standard model for ai is that we develop
algorithms that optimize a fixed known
objective
for example chess programs try to
checkmate the opponent
navigation apps find the least cost
route to a given destination
reinforcement learning algorithms
maximize the sum of rewards and so on
and the same basic paradigm holds in
control theory in operations research in
statistics and in economics
unfortunately as we move into the real
world this paradigm fails
because we cannot specify objectives
completely and correctly
and if we make a mistake we are creating
a chess match between us and a machine
that is single-mindedly pursuing an
objective at odds with our own
eventually the machine will win and i
think this is what turing had in mind
to the ai the worse the outcome
so maybe the standard model is wrong
if we can't specify objectives correctly
it's insane to build machines
that require fully specified objectives
and then treat them as gospel truth
instead we need machines that know that
they don't know the true objective
which is our true preferences about the
future
even though that's what they must pursue
so this new model for ai is strictly
more general than the old one but it is
still solvable we call this an
assistance game in the algorithms that
solve assistance games behave in new
ways
they ask permission before carrying out
plans that change the world in ways
whose values they don't know they form
minimally invasive plans that change the
world as little as possible
and they allow themselves to be switched
off
in general they're characterized by the
flow of preference information from
humans at runtime and it is rational for
us to deploy such algorithms because
they are provably beneficial to us
we're just at the beginning phase of
developing the new model
and there is a vast research agenda that
brings in questions from moral
philosophy social sciences cognitive
science neuroscience and so on
the arrival of general purpose ai is
quite unpredictable which means it's
important to be prepared
in my view that means steering ai in a
new direction
sooner rather than later
[Music]
steering area in a new direction let's
keep that point in mind as we go into
the break because it's time for a break
i'm gonna ask you to stay seated for a
second as i say goodbye first to those
watching online you're gonna be back at
6 p.m geneva time for a new session
talking about innovation curiosity and
creativity plus a surprise at the end of
this session we're gonna cut the live
stream now see you then 6 pm geneva time
goodbye for now
and for us here
for us here is going to be a bit of a
strange break because you know all the
constraints so wear your mask at all
times unless you are drinking we're
going to serve drinks but not food
because you're not permitted to serve
food remember distance if you need to
use the bathroom it's downstairs outside
through the small brown
tunnel to the right and please be back a
couple of minutes before six so we can
start on time i'll see you later thank
you
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
another great visualization from studio
ouch so welcome back for the second
session of the sparks forum
uh from the beautiful globe of science
and innovation in geneva this session is
about
strong ais about how much of today's
research focuses on mimicking on
simulating the human brain and also what
role can advances in neuroscience play
in doing in doing that
the first segment
features two speakers one virtual one
here
then we focus on the idea of ai
mirroring us
uh the first speaker comes from
boston he's gonna darlene from boston ed
boyden is a professor of neurotechnology
at mit and codex the mit center for
neurobiological engineering and the
question for him is andy is going to
have a presentation about that can
mapping the brain help us simulate it ed
are you with us
wonderful ed hi
hi sparks and uh why those just to jump
into your presentation and then we will
have another and then at the end i'm
going to ask you a couple of questions
ed boyden honorable thank
you it's great to get to talk to you
today about um what we're trying to do
in terms of mapping the brain
um if we really understood the brain
could that help us simulate things like
decisions and emotions thoughts and
feelings which could potentially yield
insights into new kinds of ai
clearly the human brain can do things
that are unparalleled by any other
technology
and yet how the brain works is still a
mystery
now one of the big things we're putting
forth is the idea that new technologies
from mapping and controlling the brain
might yield new data sets that could
help us with this quest of simulating
brain computations
the key issue is that the brain is very
very complicated
so if we really want to understand the
brain to the point where we can make
biologically realistic comprehensible
models of how brain circuits work we
need to have new tools
and there's another topic not really
relevant to today's discussion which is
of course brain diseases affect
countless people around the world none
of which can be fully cured if we could
find out how the brain map is changing
maybe we could help people
so i'll tell you two short stories today
about technologies we're developing to
control
and map the brain that we hope will
yield data sets that could enable maybe
someday not too long from now
simulations that are biologically
realistic and maybe human understandable
now let's start with napping the brain
is incredibly spatially complicated a
cubic millimeter of your brain will
contain around a hundred thousand brain
cells called neurons with incredibly
complex geometry
and within that cubic millimeter there
will be about one billion connections
between those neurons
so this is incredibly complex how can
you see the wiring and it's not just the
wiring all those cells are chock full of
molecules there are tens of thousands of
genes of the human genome and those
genes encode for so many biomolecules
countless biomolecules that are inside
those cells and between the cells that
make them do what they do
but it's worse
the temporal dimension of the brain is
also complicated if you want to
understand learning and memory
development and aging these processes
take place over months even years
but the high speed computations of the
brain take place
at milliseconds
electrical pulses that brain cells
generate that help them compute and
millisecond time scale chemical
exchanges between brain cells as well
so today i'll tell you two short stories
about how we're trying to help
neuroscience cross space and time to
collect the data sets that may someday
enable simulations of brain circuits
let's start with space how can we map
the molecules throughout brain cells and
the brain cells throughout large scale
networks
well many people have developed
technologies for imaging the brain i
think we've all seen pictures like this
a brain scan these are non-invasive and
therefore are used very widely in
neuroscience but each of those yellow
blobs that light up contains millions
sometimes even billions of brain cells
so you can't get the fundamental amount
at the other extreme is the microscope
that's how brain cells were discovered
in the first place over a century ago
but light which is what the microscope
sees has a finite size or wavelength and
therefore you cannot see the very fine
wiring of the brain or the molecules
with a conventional light microscope
so we started thinking we often do the
opposite of what people are doing what
if you could take the kind of swellable
polymer that you find in baby diapers
now if you add water to the swallowable
polymer it'll grow an experiment that
millions of babies do every day
the water is absorbed and the polymer
threads swell apart and that's how the
baby diaper works
what if we could weave chemically a
dense spider web-like mesh of the baby
diaper polymer
inside brain cells and outside brain
cells in between molecules and around
biomolecules in short all the way
throughout a specimen of the brain
we call this technique that our group
invented expansion microscopy in the
panel b you can see a small piece of the
mouse brain the panel c shows the same
piece of mouse brain tissue after we
crossed it through processed it with our
expansion protocol we've swallowed it by
a hundred times in volume about four and
a half times in each direction and what
that means is now we can make nanoscale
tiny things into large-scale observable
things
a regular old microscope can now become
a nano-imaging device
you can take interesting molecules like
fluorescent proteins from jellyfish and
coral and express them in brain cells in
this movie you can see a piece of the
brain where we did just that we gave
each brain cell a color code and then we
expanded it
our hope is by color-coding brain cells
and expanding them we can now get
unprecedented maps of the molecules
throughout brain circuits and the brain
circuits that mediate complex things
like
thinking and emotion
maybe if we have enough detail we can
even simulate these brain circuits
in action
now what about the time axis it's great
to have a map of the brain but at any
moment the brain might be doing
something something different than it
was a minute ago
the brain is generating high speed
electrical pulses
what if we could control those
electrical pulses by delivering light
onto the brain cells and the brain cells
are equipped with little solar panels so
they can respond to the light the solar
panels basically convert light to
electricity
now the brain doesn't feel pain so we
can bring in light through optical
fibers or other implantable optics
then the question becomes how do we make
brain cells sense light where do those
solar panels come from
well it turns out all over the tree of
life you can find in single-celled
organisms like this algae you see in
this cartoon
little molecules that convert light into
electrical signals
this is a single celled algae with an
eye spot or just about to zoom into it
the ice blots full of molecules that act
like little solar panels when they're
hit by light from the sun they convert
the light to electrical signals and
that's how this algae will see and helps
it navigate around bodies of water
now we're very fortunate this solar
panel is not made out of silicon it's a
protein
and that means it's encoded by a gene
and we can take the gene that encodes
for this protein
and transplant it into the brain using
viruses
vectors that are used commonly in the
field of gene therapy to put genes into
the human body or in animal models of
diseases to try to cure them
turns out this is a small gene a small
piece of dna and so it fits directly
into a common gene therapy vector that's
even used in human gene therapies
a brain cell will take up this piece of
dna and this is where serendipity struck
the brain cells started to make this
protein the solar panel like protein and
install it all over the brain cell
and amazingly it worked but we shined
light on the brain cell
that the molecules were activated and
the brain cell fired off an electrical
pulse
much like the electrical pulses that
your auditory system of your brain is
creating right now as i say these words
flash forward to the current day we now
have several classes of these molecules
which will take light and activate or
shut down brain
cells so our hope is we can start to
make these models by making maps of the
brain
and using optical methods to activate
brain cells to figure out what specific
cells do
the map then helps us interpret what
those impacts of the electrical pulses
mean in terms of the network
now how do we actually go about doing
this
i'll just end on this thought let's
start with small brains
worms and fish have hundreds of
thousands of neurons
mice have hundreds of million let's say
and the human brain has 100 billion but
if we start to model small brains maybe
we'll learn a lot about how brain
circuits work and even small brains can
do quite complex things after all they
survive in the natural world with all
this complexity so hopefully this will
help us in the future to generate models
of how brain brains compute and that
might have interesting impacts on many
fields including ai
[Applause]
thank you eddie i'm gonna
meet you again at the end of the next
talk so stay stay with us
we now hear from a philosopher
uh his work touches on ethics
epistemology bioethics and other things
material is the director of the center
for bioethics and an affiliated
professor at new york university mature
stage is yours
[Applause]
ais are getting smarter and smarter they
can already beat humans at the ancient
game of go
identify cancer tissues and do backflips
some people are really worried that ais
are going to be so smart that either
they're going to cause humans to go
extinct or turn us all into their slaves
so
about this
well to compete
with super intelligent ais
some people have said that we need to
become ais ourselves
in other in other words if you can't
fight them you should join them
but is this even possible can we become
ais with human level intelligence such
as
sentience
consciousness and moral agency also
known as strong ai
let's take a look at three ways of doing
this see whether one of them is better
than the others
so one way to create a strong ai is
through brain emulation or also known as
mind uploading
and to do this you first you do a high
resolution scan of the brain capturing
all the neurons and their synaptic
connections
you can then create a soft software
analog of these connections and then you
put it put the software analog on
appropriate hardware
now if the brain emulation
is successful then it should produce
all the essential functional
characteristics of the original brain
and then you can put the emulated ai in
a simulation or put in a robotic body so
that it can interact with the uh
external world
and actually many groups around the
world are already
working on brain emulation
so for example the
eu's human brain initiative
is uh is already actively trying to map
and
emulate the brain of a mouse and parts
of the human brain
the u.s brain initiative and the human
connectom project
are actively trying to map the the
neural pathways of the human brain
and recently there's a startup company
called necto
that is offering terminally ill patients
the possibility of preserving their
brains so that they can be emulated at a
later date
but here it's important to note that
even though you can create a strong ai
this way
that ai is not going to be you
and
to see this just imagine that you
continue to exist
alongside this newly created ai
well you're not going to be this newly
created ai
so that newly created ai cannot be you
so if you care about
when you become an ai if you care that
just creating more than a copy of you
then brain emulation is not going to
work
here's a second way to create a strong
ai and that's through direct programming
and
algorithms
so some people have suggested that
we gather all the moral rules for
example do no harm respect others and we
teach
ais how to follow these rules
others have said that maybe what we
should do
is hard code moral theories like
consequentialism deontology and virtue
ethics into ais
these ais might then be able to use
these moral theories to decide what's
right or wrong
but it's not clear you can create a
strong ai this way
for one thing there are infinite there
could be infinite numbers of moral rules
in addition
moral theories like consequentialism and
deontology often disagree with one
another
another
but more importantly
it's not clear that uh
an ai that's created this way would be
able to understand whether something is
right or wrong
if an ai just follows the rules that we
give it
and doesn't really understand the
rationales behind those rules
in what in what sense does it really
have moral agency
here maybe a more uh here's another way
that might be more plausible
for creating ai's
strong ais through computer programming
and algorithms
so across cultures
people tend to use similar building
blocks when thinking about morality so
for example our moral evaluations tend
to focus on things like agents their
intentions and the consequence of their
actions
and scientists and philosophers have
suggested that the
mind might be equipped
we might have some sort of moral faculty
that uses these building blocks to
arrive at moral judgments
so possibly we could use algorithms to
generate features like agency
intentions and consequence
we might then be able to create an
artificial moral faculty that can use
these building blocks to generate moral
judgments
but again here even though you can
create a strong ai using
programming and algorithms
this ai is also not going to be you
as an analogy if we were to build a car
that resembles your current car
well that new car is not going to be
your current car
here's the third way to create a strong
ai and it's
uh to do this basically what you do is
you take the brains uh
carbon-based cells and you gradually bit
by bit and replace them with inorganic
substitutes that function in the same
way
and you do this until all the
carbon-based cells are replaced with the
inorganic ones
and already
researchers have developed artificial
neurons that can transmit
electrochemical signals and communicate
with biological neurons
and let's assume that life-sustaining
processes such as respiration and
metabolism are maintained throughout
gradual substitution and there's no
interruption to your consciousness
well the idea here is that
if someone had moral agency that is if
they can tell right from wrong before
gradual substitution
then they the resulting ai should have
more agency after gradual substitution
now importantly
since the life-sustaining processes
respiration metabolism and so on and so
forth are maintained
throughout this process what this means
is that your organismic functions
continue to work
and there's a philosophical view that
says that you continue to be you and
exist
when your organismic functions continue
to work
for example you are the same person as
you were yesterday because your
organismic functions continue
continue to work from yesterday to today
so through gradual substitution you
could
uh continue to be you and exist even as
you become an ai
but here i want to qualify that you know
it's even an op it's an open question
whether there will even be super
intelligent ais
and also even if there are super
intelligent ais it's not clear that the
best way to compete with them is to
become an ai ourselves
suppose that we're the goal
and if you care
that when you create the ai it's more
than just a copy of you
then gradual substitution may be our
best bet
indeed the survival of the humanity
itself may depend on this thank you
thank you thank you matthew we should
have had still be fast yet again
so this was no pun intended totally
mind-boggling i was kind of visualizing
the gradual substitution and uh
and uh and and so so uh
ed
to better understand the brain it's
interesting to map it and you have found
very smart and clever ways to expand
space and and things like that but if we
reverse the question
uh
can ai help us better understand the
brain which we really don't yet
that's what you add
yes absolutely um i mean
ai and machine learning and and computer
science in general is very powerful and
uh many people are using ai and machine
learning to analyze the images of the
brain that we and many other people are
trying to acquire these image data sets
are enormous and so turning the raw
images into network diagrams uh
benefits greatly from ai and machine
learning and that's just the tip of the
iceberg you know people looking at
behavior people looking at dynamics of
the brain
ai and machine learning are having
impact in all those areas
now you talked about very tangible
things like worms and fish and
using parts of their brains to do the
experiments you do and uh matthew took
us to this place of uh you know gradual
substitution and uh and mind uh
uploading so a question for both of you
if there is a spectrum from 0 to 100
where 0 is no ai and 100 is absolute
mimicking of the human brain
where on that spectrum are we today
matthew first well i think we're close
to zero okay so ed
uh yeah i i have to concur i think the
brain is so full of mystery and and so
much feeling activity below the well
below the hood that we don't understand
there is a lot of discussion about
directly connecting the human mind with
machines right anything from companies
funded by elon musk to academic research
etc what's your take on that
that's what you have
oh connecting brains to machines yeah
well hundreds of thousands of people
already have neural implants for uh
cochlear implants for people suffering
from deafness or
deep brain stimulators for helping
people with parkinson's disease or other
movement disorders so
this has been going on since the you
know since in earnest since the
mid-1980s frankly um i think there's
clear benefit to to many patients and as
people make better and better maps of
the brain hopefully we can help more and
more people who are suffering from
different conditions from epilepsy to
alzheimer's and beyond
matthew when you think of your three
models mind uploading
coding the brain mimicking algorithms or
gradual substitution
what happens to human consciousness in
those three models so the assumption
there is that human consciousness will
be it will continue but it doesn't have
to so we actually don't know so they're
actually there are three possibilities
when you do say for example gradual
substitution
one possibility is as you do it
uh consciousness completely disappears
another possibility is that it dims
okay and then the third possibility is
that consciousness is maintained
now the supposition here is that so the
gradual substitution is something like
this so we you know you come in you go
into the clinic so you know we take one
of these artificial neurons maybe you
have alzheimer's so we take the you know
the bad cell the bad brain cell and
replace it with a good cell and then you
go back home and you're interacting and
it seems like you have consciousness
right just one now we you know a couple
couple weeks later you go into you know
you're you know you're not feeling well
you go into the clinic and you say
doctor i'm not feeling well so they say
they take out a couple more cells right
and again you go home and you're you
know talking to your wife and you know
your kids and so on and so forth and
it appears that you still have
consciousness
now the the idea the hypothesis is that
well
at some point if you continue to be able
to act
right
and it's you're you're sort of
either you're faking it because all of a
sudden consciousness disappeared or it
dimmed right like somehow you say oh i
feel pain but you don't really know
anything
or you have you know full consciousness
and it seems like uh the the last option
is more plausible than the other two
through gradual substitution but that's
an unknown so okay i think that you're
taking us to a space there that is going
to broke a lot of thinking in all of us
in the in the next in the next weeks and
months matthew thanks for your talk ed
thanks for being with us uh enjoy the
rest of the day thank you thank you
thank you thank you
so to headline the next statement
segment just a very very simple question
what may happen next two speakers to
address that
first max welling he's the research
chair
uh in machine learning at the university
of amsterdam and is also a distinguished
distinguished scientist at microsoft
research max the stage is yours
thank you well it's certainly
intimidating to be here in front of all
of these brilliant minds and following
up on these really insightful beautiful
talks
um but claudia said i should have fun so
i'm gonna try to at least have fun today
um
without a doubt
ai has brought us wonderful tools
so
when you type a query into google
you'll get a very intelligent answer
powered by a very sophisticated
ai engine
nowadays we can talk into our phones
which wasn't really possible 10 years
ago at least the part that your phone
actually understood but you say and you
can almost instantaneously translate it
into another language
we now have real-time video analysis
where you can segment the objects
and classify them and actually have real
scene understanding
and of course recently and also
featured in the previous talk
deepmind actually solved more or less
the problem of protein folding by giving
as input the sequence of amino acids and
then predicting the 3d shape of that
protein
but there's much more on the horizon
there's promise of self-driving cars
or maybe actually sell flying cars
there's going to be autonomous
agriculture
and self-regulating greenhouses
there's going to be much more
sophisticated robots that can walk like
humans
there's intelligent chat bots that can
actually maintain
a conversation like you're really
talking to a person
and there might be automated chip design
that can sort of keep
moore's law going
now of course the greatest promise of
all that we've discussed here today
is artificial general intelligence what
it precisely means
let alone
but
let me say at least my view on this or
my my belief perhaps is more
appropriate intelligence really has many
many manifestations
and human intelligence is just one of
them
now the fact that we are here is
basically an existence proof that in the
long run we will be able to build it out
of you know artificial components as
well
and that immediately implies
that such an artificial intelligence
will experience free will
it will be creative
and it will
at least experience consciousness or it
can experience consciousness
now i think we do need we don't need any
new fundamental laws
uh to discover in order to understand
intelligence
so sorry for those particle physics
physicists here at cern we really don't
need any more particles to understand
intelligence
what we do need is to understand how
intelligence emerges out of complexity
how neural information processing
systems will eventually produce into
artificial intelligence
and another important part of that is
probably embodiment we want to put that
complex brain into a body so that it can
interact with the world around it
so how do we reach ai so we may not need
more fundamental laws but we certainly
need better ai and smarter machine
learning algorithms
it turns out there's two camps in our
field
there's the camp that says
we need to scale this all up more data
more compute
bigger models and the biggest models
nowadays have over a trillion parameters
there's the other camp that basically
argues for something like the opposite
saying no no no we need to be smarter
about this
we need to inject inductive biases into
our system
the laws of physics
laws of sociology and psychology
causality we need to inject common
knowledge in terms of maybe knowledge
graphs and we need to be able to reason
with those symbols that we create that
way
now that many of these actually
come down to the fact that we can
actually simulate the world around us
and to make this a little bit more
interactive i want to do a little sort
of thing and i want to ask you to
imagine
a blue elephant on a unicycle cycling on
the moon
i think nobody has any trouble doing
this
yet there will never be a blue elephant
cycling on a unicycle on the moon and
when i ask you okay now the you the
elephant reaches the
the uh the draw a big drop into a crater
you can see the poor elephant tumble
down and fall off
of his uh his chair his unicycle
so we have the ability not just to
simulate the world we have the ability
to manipulate it and
you know predict its consequences and
even better we can do this
we can generalize this to situations
that will never ever happen
i think that's very powerful and that's
what we need for intelligence
so another important part is if we are
going to build intelligence we really
need to make sure it will benefit
humanity and society it needs to be fair
that means non-discriminatory it needs
to be transparent it should be able to
explain itself it needs to be
uncountable and certifiable
it needs to be confidential respect our
privacy and it needs to be collaborative
we need to be able to interact with it
and help us
many people
also in the previous talks worry about
a.i that could actually end humanity
now i'm not going to say that that's not
going to happen i mean
yes this is a good topic to study and it
might happen in my opinion in the very
far future not that we get destroyed
destroyed but at least that we can
create something that is equally
powerful as a human
but it's not something that i am
waking over every night and the reason
is that i think there are more urgent
and imminent dangers to humanity that
are common from humanity itself
and where ai can actually pay play an
important role in solving it and i
personally find it more interesting to
think about that and of course i'm
talking about climate change
so i predict that the next disruption is
not going to be that we are going to
build agi
i think the next disruption is
maybe a little more modest that we're
going to understand matter and life much
better at the molecular scale
and the applications that can come out
of that are really
wonderful we can probably design new
drugs on demand
we can build hydrogen-based energy
batteries
we can design room temperature
superconductivity
we can build or design green fertilizers
and biodegradable materials such as
plastics
so i believe this is a very worthy topic
topic and i actually believe that we are
on the verge
of making big breakthroughs in this
particular domain
there's a number of things that are
coming together
namely in the sciences are improving
fast condensed metaphysics computational
chemistry and molecular biology
um
it starts to collide and converge with a
number of really important modeling and
computing paradigms such as
computational science cloud computing
machine learning and quantum computing
and then i already talked about the you
know the applications which will drive
sort of injection of finance of budget
into that
now humanity two and a half million
years ago humanity started to use stones
to build tools that was the stone age
it was followed by the bronze age and
then the iron age and then much more
recently we started to construct steel
and glass
aluminum
and many other materials that you see
around you
i'm going to end by asking you to
imagine what would the world look like
where you can order any desired material
or drug on demand
thank you very much
thank you thank you max
so a second voice on ai and innovation
is anglimgo who is a senior vice
president and cto for for ai at hewlett
packard enterprise he also has two other
titles he's collaborating with nasa on a
project aboard the international space
station
to use ai for future exploration and is
also working on predicting the
predisposition to vaccine side effects
by machine learning of gene expression
data
let's see it from him and then we're
going to have a discussion and the stage
is yours thank you bruno
i'll be talking today about how to
accelerate
ai learning
as well as mitigate bias
since this is a public forum i'll start
with this statement
data
is the source of a machine learning to
be artificially intelligent
by machine here i mean
say a software program
that is defining a bunch of adjustable
dials
called weights
and by learning i mean you feed data in
tweak the dials and keep doing that
until you achieve a prediction of the
accuracy you want
but all this is dependent on the data
you feed it with right at the top
and this is the topic today that is data
is mostly siloed
either
realistically or either effectively
right by that i mean it could be silent
because of privacy reasons
privacy personal privacy country
sovereignty
security
or it could be siloed effectively
because of huge volumes
like huge volumes of petabytes of data
generated every experiment for example
impractical to move
so data is effectively or realistically
siloed
with silos comes bias
let me give an example in healthcare
if you have if you own a hospital
and you are seeing a patience of a
certain demographics around your
hospital
and then training your patients data
with machine learning in hopes you can
predict with precision uh
diagnostics right a diagnosis of a case
the problem with that is that ultimately
you'll be biased to the demographics of
the patients you are seeing
now your hope is that you can collect
data from all over the world's hospital
combine all that global data and train
the model based on that
well gdpr and other privacy requirements
regulations will prevent that
so what is the solution
the solution is a network of ai system
the solution is distributed training but
in a much more scalable way we believe
so solution is this
the local hospital
will train
based on the demographics of the
patients they are seeing
and then regularly the blockchain comes
in
collect all your neural network weights
adjustable dials up to that point
and then the blockchain averages it
across all the hospitals of the world
and then what you get back is the global
average weights
and then you update your model with that
and you continue continue learning
locally
and if you keep doing this we have shown
that it is predicting in a generalized
more generalized way as though you had
collected all the data globally and
trained on one model
the result is swarm learning i i we were
very concerned about linking machine
learning with blockchain two very
established methods right and worried
about the flaws in it that we insisted
on
putting it through peer review and it is
now on the june 10th
issue of nature and on its cover if
you're interested give it a read
now
i would say that there is federated
learning before swarm learning right
federated learning
does the same thing of distributed
learning learning locally and then
regularly
a central authority collects your
weights averages it and send it back
down the central authority is one of the
members hospital around the issue with
that with many of the institutions we
work with is that you are giving a
little bit more power and authority and
influence to that designated collector
so that's the reason why we decided to
switch out that designated collector
with a private permission blockchain
well
the idea here is therefore
you do not share any of your private
data
it doesn't leave your location all you
share are the learnings globally
thank you
a sort of meta learning in a in a in a
way and
you brought in the word blockchain by
the way for the first time today so
nobody else nobody else used it but it
seems to be
looked at as a potential solution for a
whole host of problems but tell me your
research about swarm learning was based
on healthcare data how do you translate
this to other fields
yes we have released oh by the way
imagine if it was a blockchain and then
you have a
hundred thousand hospitals of the world
all connected the minute you of course
is the private permission blockchain you
need a notary to approve members to it
but once it's done the blockchain lives
on its own like many of the tokens you
see here so the goal is a network of ai
that is almost like a living or organism
constantly learning globally
yeah so that that's the that's the key
point i'm trying to make sorry your
question uh can you apply this to other
sectors and healthcare we have
assignments also imagine credit card
companies
right uh competing ones i won't name
them but competing ones right
they want to keep their customer data
proprietary
there's another reason for privacy here
but it is appropriate trainers
but they know that all the fraud they
are seeing
from the data they have
is not a comprehensive one and they know
that they are competing
credit card companies may be seeing
other kinds of fraud that they are not
seeing and then vice versa
so this is one idea where if we can have
a notary to have all these different
competing credit card companies come in
share learnings but not any of the
private customer data
they will be much stronger together
against fraud okay so you can apply this
to many other areas including um
well i you know we have to be very
careful here about robots right
robots of the world unite imagine right
by blockchain and learning on their own
that's the reason why i was very
intrigued by um i think deepmind who
mentioned that there need to be a
control mechanism in there that's why
we're very con focused on the fact that
it needs to be a private blockchain with
a smart contract capability and we put
all the control and rules mechanism uh
in there including some of the rules
that's where russell told us yes yes i'm
learning a lot today to what sort of
rules to put in there yes in a smart
contract but this discussion of data and
the idea that that ai's output is based
on what kind of data input we can we can
provide
that seems to me to mean that
we can really uh
only use ai for anything that can be
turned into data real or synthetic but
if something cannot be turned into data
then
we can't
put it into an ai
or maybe the situation is slightly more
subtle which is um
data doesn't necessarily have to come
externally so the data could actually be
generated by a
very sophisticated sort of physical
simulator
internally into your own computer like
you can imagine uh you know alphago
playing many many games all in silico
creating sort of a virtual data set and
then you can have the machine learning
algorithm trained from that to sort of
shortcut
the sort of the simulator so i think
machine learning is actually also very
interesting solution for those types of
problems and you see them a lot in sort
of applications of machine learning to
to natural sciences for instance where
you have simulators often available
but you want to train predictors
they're just an interesting point in
fact of simulated data we work with
autonomous car companies and they need
to drive lots of miles right you know to
collect enough data to train their
billions and trillion parameter network
and uh they have on this particular road
uh driven the car in in good weather
conditions in rain at night in snow but
no hail
right well you're not going to wait for
hail right
right so what they do is they use the
snow visuals to run simulation in front
to create hail in a simulation to train
the cars with so yes in certain cases
not all right highly regulated
industries wouldn't allow simulated data
to train machines with
but uh you know autonomous car industry
they do that
max on that point you made about the two
camps field uh
essentially brute force versus versus
being smart
which one is winning
oh that's a complicated question so i i
really don't know the answer honestly um
i think it's you know the the most safe
but also what i think actually is
probably the best answer is it's
probably both so i don't think
just get there by scaling i think we
really need a couple of more
you know innovations in the field of
machine learning and ai
but obviously it is very important and
much of the progress has actually been
achieved by scaling
so we cannot deny both camps i think
they need to come together at some point
okay let's see if we have a question
from
those watching on social media
doesn't a moral strong ai need to have
consequences for its actions
who wants to take that
it's not really our domain i mean
anya could much better answer this
question but yeah i i've been asked that
question a lot right uh tough one to
answer yeah you know there'll be so many
different opinions but my opinion is for
today when we implement implement an ai
system and we are concerned about
consequences it makes we have to fence
it with rules so this needs to be a mix
of rules
and
an ai system that's learning from data
external or simulator so these rules the
fencing around that ai system is
necessary
and that's the reason why when we picked
same thing back to the point of
blockchain we made sure that that
particular blockchain had had a smart
contract capability in it to apply a
contract
right with the ai system right to
disallow it from certain actions
um and and the consequences could be it
could be allowed to be shut down yeah
can you answer maybe also so we have to
be very careful about this i think you
have to make sure that the consequences
also lie with the humans that create the
strong ai because if not if the only
you know if you say to a robot you've
done something terrible and now we're
going to disensem disassemble you it
might not care that much right so it
might not really
change its actions based on that that uh
penalty so i think it's the humans
really in the end that construct those
things that still need to keep
responsibility that's a good point right
why i mentioned data right if your data
is biased the machine will be right
so there is a huge responsibility i
believe going forward that
the data feeders of ai systems right
needs to be proportionals yeah yeah it's
one of the conundrums of responsibility
for autonomous driving for example right
this is an accident who's responsible
the person is supposed to be in the car
the owner of the car the producer of the
software the producer manufacturer of
the car the owner or and so on and so on
gentlemen thank you for coming to
suspense thank you very much
so we've still quite a bit of ground to
to cover and the next chapter explores
whether ai can learn to ask
questions and make real contributions
autonomous contributions to
science we've asked first the question
to uh hiraki kitano he's the ceo of sony
ai and the president of uh and ceo of
sony computer science labs
and it comes to us via video let's watch
[Music]
hi
today i would like to introduce you
a new grand challenge that is the noble
chilling challenge
as its name indicate this is the
challenge to make ai system that can
make a
high impact scientific disciplines
now the goal in the question is can we
build highly autonomous ai robotic
system that can make series of major
science discoveries your nobel prize and
even beyond can we build this such a
machine
by 2050 for example and that is the goal
of the challenge
and you might ask
you know
can ai system can win actually with a
nobel prize okay we have to satisfy two
things one ai system have to be able to
make a major sign discovery and the
second thing is nobel committee
is going to award the system without
noticing if that is the human beings in
order to accomplish this ai system has
to be able to accomplish two things
one is the scientific discovery that is
to ai system should be able to make a
major scientific skill you know just one
property like a series of scientific
discovery highly or
fully autonomously and of course not
just discover how to be able to
communicate in problem publications and
explain you know reasoning behind the
discovery
now
second making discovery is one thing but
at the same time discovery has to be
significant for our civilizations so you
have to be able to make a strategic
choice of the research and explain the
value and potential applications and
social implications that mean the ai
system need to align with the value
system our civilization
okay so two sub goals that are very
interesting each of them are worthy of
investigating
now some of you may ask
you know if that is like a machine how
people take it seriously but at the same
time like if you remember the bitcoin
blockchain
it was started from the blog post as the
person named satoshi nakamoto obviously
this is a japanese name but no one ever
met satoshi nakamoto and we don't know
who it is if that is like an individual
or a group of people and the only reason
we believe this is not artificial
intelligence is we know ai is not good
enough so you know it doesn't really
matter
whether
big inventions or a big discovery is
made by the machine or human being if
that is significant we take it it gets
proven
by the bitcoin and blockchain
now
computationally this was interesting
challenge and we have to think what is
the process of scientific discovery and
we talk about serendipity or fortunate
accident or scientific conditions what
does that mean
so by moving forward with this challenge
we'll dig deep into the computational
aspect of serendipity scientific
intuitions are a process of scientific
discovery and probably we're going to
reformulate scientific discovery in a
way that is more exhaustive and
potentially more effective this is very
interesting challenge because
this
means
system have to be able to continuously
make major discovery
or discover it continuously at scale
highly autonomously or fully
autonomously and able to communicate
and write the papers communicate and
provide the reason you know what's going
on behind the discovery at the same time
discovery have to be aligned with
our value otherwise discovery would not
be considered as important so like a
strategic choice of the topic
and then the communicating implication
of the discovery and then communicating
with their peers and in the general
public would be the another challenge
which makes ai system more valuable and
that makes
more human-like but at the same time the
question is
the pattern of scientific discovery by
that machine would mimic human
scientific discovery or make it
something very different
that would be very interesting question
because
you know patent or process of discovery
may not be the same as a human
discovery process so we maybe actually
end up de-formulating the scientific
discovery process by machines
now 20 plus years ago i proposed systems
biology and if you look at the progress
systems biology it
became mainstream in biomedical science
and everyone's talking about systems
biology in every school had some kind of
system biology one or the other at the
same time
we are
you know having hard time scaling up a
precision model at a large scale so like
in system biology community there are
either high precision model in a small
scale
or large scale model or data
of
analysis based on the more the
statistical approach
it is still not possible to create a
large scale precision model of the
mechanical model
even
20 years of the system by research and i
concluded system biology is the science
for the artificial intelligence or ai
hybrid system
one of the reasons
is the human cognitive limitations
because we can't really tackle very
large amounts of knowledge or data and
in a very complex situation so you know
either we cannot access the information
so knowledge and we can't really keep
handling this at a large scale and
that's what the
ai or machine is good at so i think like
the way we move forward in system
biology or probably other sciences with
a similar nature
is to have like a hybrid system in
between a human being and artificial
intelligence now of course
ai for scientific discovery is nothing
new i mean there's the history of the
dendrometer dendro
am euresco and others and the most
recently
ross king's
you know
robot scientist which is automating uh
east genetics uh hypo generations
designing uh experiment and actually run
expand and verify that it's a closed
route system
you know so now i think it's a great
opportunity in front of us that we can
augment such a system and combine
several ai approach and the large-scale
data generation capabilities and robust
capability to be able to create highly
automated
multifunctional and open-ended system
to generate hypotheses run experiments
and verify that and keep going and then
create scientific discovery at scale
i think this approach of the ai based on
this discovery may change the way we
think
the way we run the science because at
this moment we consider scientific
intuitions important asking right
questions important
however
those things was not fade away it's not
gonna totally go on but like with the
machine creating hypothesis exhaustively
done experiments
and verify that
crude open system highly autonomously
may change the way we approach things so
this is extremely important uh project i
hope like everyone to each project and
it could be the new
challenge that the scientific community
will engage
thank you very much
[Music]
wow
and we thought that only
kind of
office work accountants would be
threatened by ai uh
but this is supposed to be a a
conference about future intelligence but
the impression there is also a side
business in future creation because you
know we got
the image of the brain and gradual
substitution and then we got
the pampers uh
liquid in the brain and the cells and
make them more distance and of course
the blue elephant on the unicycle uh on
the moon and now we just got this image
of the nobel prize ceremony what is up
what would happen what how would it like
look like if an ai wins the nobel prize
no who picks up the prize uh is it a
robot is a disembodied voice is it gonna
be one of us as an ambassador of the
ai it's a really interesting kind of
line of thought anyway if you're
interested in the touring challenge that
uh iraqi just outlined there is a nature
paper that describes it all in in detail
and for now let's just continue the
exploration of this theme of creativity
can i
uh think outside the box we're joined by
vivienne ming a theoretical
neuroscientist inventor i have it on
high authority that she also calls
herself a mad scientist vivienne are you
with us she has among modern many other
things led studies into how people learn
and create which of course provides
insight into how to think about
artificial creativity vivienne how are
you
i'm doing wonderfully well here in the
early morning of california excellent uh
so we're gonna hear a talk from you a
presentation and then a second one
uh and then we're gonna have a short
discussion uh the stage or the attention
rather is yours
uh well i apologize that this face is
demanding your attention but let's dive
into creativity um
so it's a big idea that we all just
heard that ai might someday win a a
nobel prize the the turing test for
science we might call it
well what can we do right now uh there's
we can we are moving towards a world in
which machine learning is playing an
increasingly
large role in science discovery a few
years ago for example i was reading
papers about wage gap written by labor
economists and and was curious about a
question that i didn't feel was being
answered why do women make different
labor choices than men
so i built a number of web crawlers that
crawled across the websites of 60 000
companies and collected data from images
of the leadership team
uh to natural language processing of
their quarterly reports and from this
massive data we made a new discovery
turns out younger women commit more
hours to their work when there are
established women in leadership roles an
interesting and unique discovery
it took me two days to collect that data
using my nlp and image analysis can you
imagine even five years ago ten years
ago certainly how many years and the
size of the army required to collect all
of that information and in fact just
over the last year or two we've seen
publications involving
analysis of the innovation in every
dissertation written in the united
states since 1972 1.2 million papers
analyzed for innovation
every biotech patent uh analyzed to see
the impact of the identity of the
inventors on the kinds of things being
invented and most recently a look at the
structure of
scientific collaboration the images of
visual artists and the screenplays of
filmmakers to look at what produces
streaks in elite creative performers all
impossible research
without artificial intelligence to do
the initial data collection using very
sophisticated criteria
like how innovative a paper is
we've also looked at how artificial
intelligence in my lab can actually
improve the collective intelligence of
groups
for example we analyzed
large online classes 30 000 students and
initially found something kind of
surprising if you put those classes up
into small cohorts of five to ten
learners rather than a giant
undifferentiated social network the
students actually learned more
even if those cohorts were random but
what if we use machine learning to pair
people together
let's say based on personality
turns out pairing people for similarity
doesn't improve their learning but
pairing them for difference does
building strategic teams of students
who share some similarities but
importantly have differences again
imagine the combinatorics of doing that
across 30 000 people
by hand but with machine learning we
begin to make progress and over the last
year well everyone has been in lockdown
we've been able to analyze the same
thing with scientific and research teams
to see the same emerging patterns
that you can actually build models to
understand which people will be most
creative together
and in theory engineer those teams to
maximize their creativity by reducing
redundancy in the things that make us
different finally
how about directly stimulating
creativity in the brain
so i have a number of companies in the
neurotechnology space in fact when i was
interviewing for grad school i told
people i wanted to build cyborgs
boy did they think i was crazy but now
we live in a world
where technologies are beginning to
interact directly with our brains such
as deep brain stimulation
um and neuroprosthetics replacing limbs
with artificial robotic limbs that
directly communicate with the brain
is there a neuroprosthetic for
creativity
well this is very early days for that
field of research but it turns out using
technologies such as transcranial
alternating current stimulation and
direct current stimulation
targeting specific parts of our brain
such as aspects of our prefrontal lobes
or our insular cortex we can actually
induce dis inhibition allowing people to
explore more ideas come up with more
unique uses for an unknown device of
meanings for different types of words
and we can also stimulate other regions
and help people with their lateral
thinking allowing them to think of
different solutions to similar problems
now
that isn't specifically about machine
learning but it turns out our brains are
so individual so
heterogeneous that in fact machine
learning is almost a fundamental
requirement to tailor these technologies
to a specific person's brain
if i wanted to induce your creativity
using these sorts of technologies we
need to build a closed loop that
actually finds just the right
alternating current to sync up the right
rhythms in your brain and it's so
exciting to be part of a moment
uh to have started a career where people
thought i was joking when i said i
wanted to make cyborgs and to now be
able to look at people that perhaps have
brain trauma
or degenerative diseases and know maybe
we can add a bit of richness back into
their life
now what about scientists
the scientist ai the independent creator
well this is the cutting edge of the
whole idea of artificial creativity and
in my lab we're looking at two different
projects
one with very young learners and the
other looking at the effects of chronic
stress on things like heart disease and
major depression
and in both cases
much as we just heard about our systems
are running continuous autonomous
real world experiments but now imagine
we're not just running autonomous lab
experiments these are affecting real
people's lives so we have to be
incredibly careful the core discovery
here is using natural language
processing to understand what are unique
in people's lives
looking for correlations with longer
term outcomes
and then our system
introduces tiny little nudges for
example for the learners we reach out to
their parents and offer them suggestions
do you have 15 minutes free tonight how
about you play this game with your child
and in each case
our system is explicitly testing a
causal relationship it has
hypothesized from the correlations that
is emerging in its own data sets
and we're looking in the same way to see
how personality mediates the effects of
chronic stress on long-term life
outcomes small nudges
causal chains
all done autonomously but at its heart
the questions being asked the
understanding of the relationships are
still fundamentally human
we're moving into a world in which a.i
is not artificial but augmented
intelligence that is supporting an
entire new generation of scientists
to go out and be curious explorers of
the world and maybe what we're going to
see is it allows us to expand what it
means to be a scientist to not just
explore the lab but the natural world
in real time
and allow citizen scientists to
participate in that discovery augmented
intelligence
is
the near-term
uh ai impact on science and i'm looking
for that day
maybe not where the ai wins the nobel
prize but where the
awardees
thank the artificial intelligence that
was the crucial tool in their discovery
we're again meet you again in a few in a
few moments
uh
a second view on the same topic
artificial creativity from vittorio
loreto he's a professor of physics
and a physicist of complex systems sorry
at universitala sapienza in rome italy
and he also is the head of the sony
computer science lab in paris vittorio
welcome
thank you very much bruno it's really
intimidating to be here
so
if i had to summarize in a few sentences
what i'm going to say today i would say
in the following
i think artificial intelligence can help
us to be more creative and i think we
may want to be more creative in this
specific moment in front of all the
challenges we face
also including the challenges imposed by
ai to us
so but let's start over let me start
with the uh the definition of creativity
of course i'm not going to give but i
leave you with these three
excellent definitions and i would say
max you've been very creative tonight
because it is an intelligence having fun
on this stage i mean 15 minutes ago so
what all these definitions have in
common i mean at least in my opinion i
guess the point is
unknown
and copic media unknown is one of the
most important activities of mankind it
always was it is now probably more than
than ever
we are hopefully entering in the
postcard phase but this phase is a sort
of
uncharted territory it's forcing us to
mean to revisit our lives our cities our
spaces our interactions so when we cope
with the unknown we are actually playing
in a very special playground so i guess
francois jacob nicely spelled out the
difference between the actual okay on
your right
and so the actual is what you experience
already in the past and the possible so
the set of things you can possibly
experience in the near future or in the
far future okay and of course then
a few years later stewart kaufman
refined india by introducing the notion
of adjacent
possible so i just and possibly the set
of all things could be ideas could be
molecules could be
technological products which are one
step away so they are adjacent one step
away from what we know already and of
course we can reach them by incremental
modifications and recombination perhaps
in the spirit of tinkering of the
existing materials of sugar caffeine was
coming from biology thinking about the
evolution in in biology
what is special about the adjacent
possible is it's not a static space it's
a space changing while you explore it
let me give you one simple example uh
with a social network so imagine that
this is a very simple social network i
pretending to be the red spot here okay
and the white spots are people i already
met in the past i can keep meeting
now for instance now i meet america and
then at some point i mean claudia and
then through claudia i can actually meet
some other person which would be the
green spot i never met before in this
case i mean this morning i would have
said fabiola but then i met fabiola
before jumping on this stage so i mean
it would be already changing but suppose
now i'm in the moment in which i'm
meeting fabiola what happens is there is
a new part of the space
appearing out of the blue
so
this part of the space cannot be
foreseen in advance unless you get to
this very point you have a novelty
experience and of course after this
there could be some other
elements that can become possible at
some later stages
so now we know a lot about the space we
constructed a mathematical structure to
treat this problem you can make a lot of
predictions out of it and check this
with data so we are quite happy on the
mathematical and physics side on this
but still we are baffled by this space
this space is really elusive
why is elusive it's elusive because of
course we don't know anything about the
green spots right so we cannot predict
all the possible outcomes all the
possibilities in front of us
of course i mean this is there is a good
reason for this because we are trying to
predict something that never happened
before so of course we don't have we
don't have a clue stay
still we
we may want to take decisions
and we want to make predictions and of
course predictions are complicated
someone said i guess was niels bohr said
predictions are very tough and difficult
especially about the future i guess you
all know this so this is complicated but
still we want to make predictions and we
have a few strategies to make
predictions also data-driven so the
typical strategies is to look at the
future with the eyes of the past so we
look at all bunch
of data from the past try to make sense
of this in some cases constructing
models out of it and then trying to
project this model into the future okay
so it's working not always working okay
but in some cases if you only rely on
the
could be highly misleading
now i mean let me just spend 30 seconds
on a joke it's not a joke actually so
this is real i mean this was a news from
the garden in 2017 self-driving cars of
volvo this is important volvo the
swedish
getting stuck in the outback of
australia in front of kangaroos
can you imagine why
of course i mean kangaroos were not in a
training set of a swedish company elks
and caribous and other stuff okay now of
course now you can teach the machine
what
kangaroo is but then there will be
next kangaroo right okay so somehow one
has to be prepared for the for the
unknown one is to be prepared for
something and we should realize that we
are living in a non-stationary system
our rules are not fixed forever they are
evolving over time
so systems are increasing the number of
states in which they they could be ai
was not there okay 70 years ago but now
i mean accelerating a lot so the rules
of the game are changing all the time
and treating no stationary system is not
it's not obvious so of course now there
is a lot of activity here this morning
also about this in order to make machine
learning
better prepared for let me say novelties
okay so online learning but of course
there are pitfalls
so catastrophic forgetting is one of
these pitfalls i would also say that
perhaps the sustainability of this kind
of computation is not obvious also for
for for other kind of reasons but still
i mean this is a very important point
how we cope with no structural systems i
give you just one example not because
it's the most important because there's
some which i'm involved it's a very
small corner
and with with a friend and colleague
alessandro londe
we're actually working on a different
kind of protocols for learning it
without dreaming learning so we let
machine dream okay what does it mean
dreaming dreaming means creating
artificial sequences out of the
knowledge already acquired up to a
certain point and of course you can tune
this generation
by a temperature so a very small
temperature you have
basically you reproduce the already
existing sequences at high temperature
you create random sequences in the
middle there could be a sweet spot the
sweet spot somehow is reminiscent of the
adjacent possible we already we have
already seen so to make the story short
i mean it seems that those machines
trained with this dreaming learning are
better prepared for
for uh for the novelties but actually
what you see here it's actually the
outcome of a prediction experiment done
on a truly uh non-stationary system in
which new characters and new elements
are appearing all the time it seems to
be working but of course i mean there is
a lot to do there is the beginning of
the journey and
it would be very very important i mean
to follow this line to get self-aware
machine self-aware also aware of the
mutated conditions so i'm getting to the
conclusion because i would say it's
important to have self our machines but
i would also argue that it would be
important to exploit i mean machines to
become more creative so i would argue
for a sort of augmented creativity which
is a sort of synergy between machine and
us i will conclude with two little
excellent we are working on our
lab in paris
which are on the one hand co-creation
processes we basically create tools for
musicians for writers to compose okay in
general and of course in this case there
is a sort of continuous dialogue between
the machine and and the human being and
an evolutionary process in which the
machine is acting as a sort of one
abilities the second example is about
sustainability so of course solving
important problems creativity is also
finding solutions for important problems
and in this case we're constructing a
lot of platform through which humans can
actually
look at the present through models and
data but also project this in a sort of
what-if experiment so what happens if i
take this action of course you need
right models i mean to do this but ai in
this sense i mean is very very helpful
because the kind of parameters is huge
and already
expanding the adjacent possible and
navigating us in this highly dimensional
space would be very important so i
conclude by saying that i would really
look forward i mean for this energy to
be true and i would also argue that this
synergy could be important also for us i
mean to understand better our our
intelligence and also to use our
intelligence to address the societal
challenges
including ai
thanks a lot for your attention
thank you victoria
take a seat yes
not the other one because here the other
one we may have
viviane if she's still with us oh yes
yes she is absolutely
i'm here
okay so vivian augmented intelligence
vittorio augmented creativity uh
so there is a similar approach here we
are near term we are technology
collaborating and helping us to augment
uh for you with an angle on creativity
for vmware angle especially on education
but but uh
not only in terms of the learning
process how how does does that does that
work when
when you start collaborating with the
machine and then when you push the
collaboration further so when you get to
the level of augmented x that each of
you pointed out how does that work
practically does it
change
the person does it change the machine
how are the forces at play there really
and maybe first
so in my experience uh having played
around with these sorts of tools for a
while
it does take a different approach and to
be clear we're exploring hypothesis
space i don't i don't think that this is
a replacement at least what we're doing
for
solid traditional lab-based science
but we're able to explore so much space
by combining what amount to
complex reinforcement learning
algorithms
with econometric models to plausibly
model the the causal relationships or
the variables we're looking at
um but in the end you know our system
truly understands the problems that it's
solving and so it requires
us to step in and say wow there's some
really interesting patterns here that
now need a deeper exploration that that
need a more mechanistic exploration and
that's maybe that that that last element
that mechanistic understanding of what's
going on
that uh our approach for example in
education and chronic stress
are lacking but that benefit of honing
down on specific hypotheses that are
really worth testing is powerful
perhaps i can give you one example which
simplifies all this so we constructed an
interactive installation which is a
physical installation actually built
with
lego bricks so people are supposed to
build the city with these lego bricks
but it's not just a game because
actually there are cameras and sensors
monitoring what is going on in this city
there are color coding each color is
coding for a specific aspect of the city
or the urban environment and underneath
there is a mathematical model which
itself has been trained through data
of existing cities okay actually this is
a mathematical model reminiscent
actually it's an italian model in which
we try to to infer the coupling
parameters so the rules of the game but
not the patterns so people are doing
something and then they get a feedback
in terms of how good is the city in
terms of certain number of parameters
quality of life
employment rate number of cars pollution
this kind of stuff then they they get
missions can you reduce the number of
cars in a city and of course there is no
lego brick for the number of cars so you
have to
to try to infer i mean which kind of
actions you have to take in this complex
space of parameters in order to get
there and the machine of course i mean
it's not now but in the future can
actually learn
from these actions i can actually try to
steer
the movements of people in this space so
it's a again it's a sort of ping pong
situation between the machine and the
human being well when we apply a problem
like that uh so kind of
uh and you you put a machine and humans
on it uh
then of course the machine has gigantic
computational power that we don't have
and so on but uh
is is there a risk that we are
essentially only looking at the city
from the perspective of what can be
measured and therefore what can be
translated into algorithmic data and we
are not looking at the other set of
issues
of course i mean there is always this
problem of the bias this is generally
still still unsolved but still i would
say that this is uh
this kind of object should not be
thought as a sort of decision theater so
you go there
and you leave with the solution these
are supposed to be awareness machines so
for humans to get ideas i mean in front
of this machine i've seen discussion of
people saying i would do this
no no i would do this would be better
for this this reason and then i said
okay why don't you try out this so this
is a way to make hypothesis for yourself
and then try out this hypothesis
according of course to the limitation of
the machine so far but still i would say
the machine is limited human beings not
and if you get a sort of
nudge
to get the right idea this i guess is
enough
if i might
expand on that it's interesting because
one of the criticisms particularly of
modern machine learning deep neural
networks is that they're black box
they're so complex we don't really
understand what they're doing
but by actually creating these
closed-loop experimental systems
it reveals if not the motivation for
lack of a better word and that's a
terrible one but the lack of a
motivation behind the experiment you
still see the experiment you see what
what the result of this experiment was
so if our system repeatedly nudges
individuals
to
increase their daily walk by ten percent
then that allows my team to then explore
that as an independent causal
relationship
admittedly that's something we already
know but what's interesting is
is heterogeneity
science generally takes specifics and
generalizes them into a general theory
but then we have this assumption we can
take that general theory and apply it
back to the specific instances what in
fact we see is
almost everything that emerges from our
analysis
that extra 10 minutes of walk every day
helps most but not all people
uh increasing your openness to new
experiences decreases stress for most
but not all people and understanding
that those unique heterogeneities
particularly given work i've done in the
past for example using ai's in hiring
which is highly ethically complex and
induces all sorts of problems if you
cannot causally say why this specific
person should be hired or not hired you
shouldn't be using that system
uh and and i think we we have the chance
to look at science in the same way
okay we just have one minute left and uh
willian forgive me but i cannot resist
uh
behind you you have your book on
machiavelli for women is there anything
machiavellian in ai
well you know i i actually loved uh as
imperfect as it is the movie ex machina
and and just the idea that an
intelligent system
uh possibly even absent self-awareness
but with the right cost functions
uh might be able to somewhat
psychopathically uh manipulate us and uh
induce uh our own ends it's certainly
people's classic fear about artificial
intelligence although i have to say
boy i wish we had that problem i've i at
least as a someone developing ai uh the
fact that i can't get the damn thing to
do the stupidest and most simple thing
most of the times i wish i had a super
intelligent ai that actually worked
uh then we could solve the machiavelli
problem okay some some grounding here
it's very welcome thank you evie and
enjoy the rest of the day in california
vitoria thank you
okay so we have one talk to go uh but
before we do that that's the closing
talk i want to take a couple of minutes
to share a few things first of all all
the videos of today are going to be
available on the sparks website uh very
very soon so you can watch them you can
share them you can suggest your friends
to go and watch them and so on there is
also a sparks podcast this one uh you
can listen to discussions uh between
some of the speakers of today and uh
many
more then i want to thank again the
partners of sparks for having supported
the wall uh project uh rolex and edmond
rochelled and la fonda
merci beaucoup thank you
then of course a big thank you an
applause goes to all the speakers of
today here and those who participated in
the forum yesterday a big thanks to them
as well
and then to the team and everybody else
was contributed to making this happening
which was definitely not an easy and
easy thing so thank you to the team and
everybody else who has helped
now the final talk of the day
by an artist
so our social and informational space
has been captured for the over the last
10 15 years by
social media systems and other
algorithmic driven
platforms and we here probably more or
less know that they feed on our personal
information they turn our behaviors and
experiences into data that's what drives
those platforms but many people feel
that this doesn't really
matter much that's just the price to pay
to use
free and useful
services and that in any case algorithms
cannot really
well know us uh uh in in in intimate
terms basically the artist in berlin and
vienna uh hans block cosima terrace and
moritz ryzevik with
their colleagues whoever found a clever
uh way to try to test that assumption
is they asked their followers on social
media because that's what we do
to volunteer to ask google and facebook
and linkedin and twitter and other
platforms
for a copy of the data that those
companies hold about them you know that
according to european union law every
citizen can ask for a copy of the data
that a company
owns and controls about them and then to
share those data
with artists and huntsblock is here to
tell us what happened next hans come up
hello
is it possible to reconstruct a person's
life based solely on their online data
their thinking speaking acting without
ever having met the person
we gave it a try
one hundred thousand data points
one life
one person
and
one double
online data reveals behavioral patterns
who we are what we're interested in and
how we're feeling at a particular moment
searched for why do i feel so empty
inside you're in a vulnerable moment and
these companies are just profiting
they're taking advantage of you we can
predict the psychology of millions of
people with really just a few clicks
searched weight loss there is an
industry that operates behind all of our
backs selling dossiers about us and our
most intimate characteristics
searched i don't want to go back home
at that moment i understood the
ramifications of this experiment
[Music]
does your data reveal who you really are
we live in a world where almost
everything we do leaves data traces
data trails that reveal something about
our interests our desires may reveal who
we are as a person
at least that's something that
researchers of
stanford and cambridge university have
been claiming
book and google can draw conclusions
about our personality and our future
behavior even more accurately than
friends partners and family could do
these studies
spread like a wildfire across the world
facebook likes predict personality
facebook's facebook knows you better
than anyone else
but is but what is really behind such
claims
what exactly do we all reveal when
online or when we use our smartphones
that's exactly what we wanted to know
my name is hans block i'm part of the
artistic group laucon and together with
uh
srivic and cosi materas we have created
an artistic experiment made to measure
the bet
is it possible to reconstruct a person's
life based solely on online data without
ever having met the person
and is it possible to create a double
based on the data
we've tried it
and to start the experiments we needed
volunteers willing to give us their data
so we launched a open call across europe
asking people to give us their personal
data
and that's exactly what people did
surprise surprise we got a lot of mails
over 100 people were willing to
participate
in our experiment
and
one data set data set 25
and
since the amount of data we could have
used would have been so rich to create a
lookalike from we decided to use only
google data
before we started filming we analyzed
the data with data analysts with data
scientists and data journalists
over 100 000 individual data points over
a period of five years on all this data
eventually becomes a movie but before
that we cast an actress who we thought
is very close to the original and then
we started filming
[Music]
i am data set 25
this is what i could look like
this is how i could laugh
how i could sleep
i don't know what to say right now uh
will we be alike
i wonder about my name
how close will i be to the original
a collection of data and me as its
embodiment the double
what made me become who i am today
do i even want to know everything about
myself
[Music]
i will become the double thanks to more
than 100 000 pieces of data and hundreds
of correlations and connections
but can you really reconstruct a human
life based solely on google data
we examined every little detail of my
data set
in order to reconstruct my life
we reconstructed all of that
[Music]
piece by piece on a stage
we reconstructed places where i might
have stayed
[Music]
reenacted daily routines as they might
have happened
revive past relationships that i might
have been in
we turned my life into a film
turned your life into a film
and your data was the script
you don't know any of that yet
[Music]
external characteristics such as height
age gender
the color hair
profession origin musical taste were
relatively easy to track down but the
insight into the life of dataset 25 went
much deeper
also highly sensitive information such
as weaknesses fears needs desires
diseases behavioral disorders we are
apparently reflected in data set
but where we write with all our
assumptions
does the data reenactment really
correspond to the life of the original
a few months later the double ganger
and the original met each other
and to be honest the encounter
really developed an increasingly
uncomfortable
reality
hello
the first meeting of the two of them
lasted more than four hours and in the
conversation the actress revealed more
details about the life the growing up in
austria in a small valley
the
career as a pastry chef in a five-star
kitchen in england
failed relationships and also a moment
where she was locked in a room with a
little gecko and didn't know what to do
but
even moments that the participant might
not like to remember
searched weight loss
searched for love yourself lyrics justin
bieber
searched intermittent fasting
searched therapist for internal crisis
the hopeful walk to the scales
checking whether i'd lost weight or not
the relief when i had lost weight
and the disappointment when the number
remained the same
[Music]
my god
[Music]
i know it's a taboo topic just very few
people talk about it
i'm here
wondering if my data would reveal it
i don't think i've ever googled the term
maybe part of the reason i'm here is to
confront a side of myself
what
else
it's not just us the artist through
blaocon who had have access to all this
sensitive information at least some of
the time
it's mainly the big companies like
google and facebook
trading such
sensitive information day by day
if advertisers
want to exploit people's vulnerabilities
weaknesses addictions
they can do so by using a global set of
rules
and if you look in this industry
standard it's called iab audiencex
taxonomy you will find interesting
things
more than 1 600 very very intimate
characteristics about people such as
interest in gambling
interest in bankruptcy
interest and death
it's even possible to target people
based on their health condition
including things like cancer stds or
mental disorder
and more worrying
authorities empowered to do something
have done nothing
the participant of our experiment
decided to stop the experiment at some
point
not only because the intimate details we
confronted her with became more and more
incriminating but also
at some point
she
couldn't tell whether this is her own
memory or the narrative we told her
at some point she couldn't longer tell
whether
these were her own memory or
this is our narrative and that was the
and that was the point we thought we
have to stop that and we understood the
power of this data
and by ending the experiment the
participant
choose to regain sovereignty uber about
her past and future
let me tell you one last thing the idea
of the
autonomous individual
is based on the assumption
that everything we do is free
we can shape our world and the future is
open
the free and open world is crumbling
because
with the proliferation of algorithmic
forecasting tools
that want to be able to predict our
future desires our future aspirations
our future action a competitive
narrative enters our free world
turning
and open
and
mainly freely creatable future
into a predictable predetermined one
it's not gods that assign a destiny for
each of everyone it's the data
those wisdom
received and transmitted by algorithms
and the more we are surrounded by these
recommendations the greater the
likelihood
that our actions allied to these
recommendations
and therefore the prophecies can become
self-fulfilling
with made-to-measure we started the
attempt to make these invisible
phenomena visible and tangible
if you want to experience the full data
experiment visit our website
mate to measure dot
online
and
it could have been that you are not only
a passive observer
but also the object of observation
thank you so much
thank you hans so closing with a strong
word of caution and of course with a
list of questions that could make for
another full conference which we may do
at some point
but uh i did go to the website and uh if
you do uh take an hour because it lasts
one hour it tells you the full story you
have several points where you are asked
questions and then there is a surprise
at the end so if you do stay until the
end it's really really interesting
okay this is the end of sparks uh
i guess that is a moment for
thanking you all here for
coming this was a very another
experience after 18 months of
being distanced and uh uh interacting
through screens thanks to all of you who
have been uh watching online thanks to
the team the speakers and the partners
uh i know that there is a thinking in
the theme about making this event annual
so stay tuned for some announcement
later this year for now
thank you stay stay safe stay well
goodbye
[Applause]
you